Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the restishistory.com and join the club. That is, the rest is history.com. This episode is brought to you by SAP.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest is History）。如需收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。没错，就是 therestishistory.com。本期节目由 SAP 赞助播出。
With investors, customers, and workers demanding more from your business, it's time to try SAP. Its AI-powered capabilities can help you streamline costs, Connect with new suppliers and manage payroll even when your business is being pulled in different directions to deliver a quality product at a fair price while paying your people what they're worth too. So your business can stay unfazed. Learn more at SAP.com slash uncertainty. This episode is brought to you by Hive. You know, history is full of transformations. The Romans shifted from Republic to Empire. The Tudor's transformed, monocetons.
随着投资者、客户和员工对您的业务提出更高要求，是时候尝试 SAP 了。其人工智能驱动的功能可以帮助您精简成本、对接新供应商并管理薪资，即使您的业务在努力以合理价格提供优质产品，同时还要支付员工应得报酬的压力下被拉向不同方向时，也能游刃有余。让您的业务保持从容不迫。详情请访问 SAP.com/uncertainty。本期节目由 Hive 赞助播出。你知道，历史充满了变革。罗马人从共和国转变为帝国。都铎王朝将修道院改造成了乡村别墅。
monasteries into country houses. And do you know what? Hive has had one of its own. Everybody knows Hive for smart thermostats, but now they've evolved into something much greater. Solar panels that help you to power your home with clean energy. Heat pumps that pull warmth from thin air. EV charges that charge your car while you're asleep. All managed through a single app. This is all about giving people the power to transform their homes. from waste to efficiency, from dependence to control, from consumption to contribution. So history's next great transformation may not be happening in parliaments or palaces. It may be happening in your home. A quiet revolution minus guillotine. Hive. Know your power.
你知道吗？Hive 也经历了自己的变革。大家都知道 Hive 的智能恒温器，但现在他们已经进化成了更伟大的事物。太阳能电池板帮助您用清洁能源为家庭供电。热泵从空气中汲取热量。电动汽车充电桩在您睡眠时为您的爱车充电。所有这些都通过一个应用程序进行管理。这一切都是为了赋予人们改造家庭的力量：从浪费到高效，从依赖到掌控，从消耗到贡献。所以，历史下一次伟大的变革可能不会发生在议会或宫殿里，它可能就发生在您的家里。一场没有断头台的静默革命。Hive，掌握你的力量。
Visit hivehome.com to find out more. Subject to survey and suitability. Hive app compatible with selected heat pumps. My dearest beloved Emma, the dear friend of my bosom, the signal has been made that the enemy's combined fleet are coming out of port. We have very little wind, so that I have no hopes of seeing them before tomorrow. May the god of battles crown my endeavors with success. At all events, I will take care that my name shall ever be most dear to you and Horatia, both of whom I love as much as my own life.
访问 hivehome.com 了解更多信息。需视勘测和适用性而定。Hive 应用程序兼容部分热泵。我最亲爱的艾玛，我心头最亲密的朋友，信号已经发出，敌人的联合舰队正在出港。风力很小，所以我没有希望在明天之前见到他们。愿战神让我的努力取得成功。无论如何，我会确保我的名字永远为您和霍拉蒂亚所珍视，你们俩都是我像生命一样热爱的人。
And as my last writing before the battle will be to you, so I hope in God that I shall live to finish my letter after the battle. So that was a letter by Admiral Horatio Nelson. It was written on the 19th of October 1805, two days before his climactic date with destiny, one of the great dates in the British calendar, Tom, the date of the most titanic naval battle of the Napoleonic Wars, Trafalgar. And Emma, well, who was Emma? Emma is Nelson's mistress, Lady Hamilton.
正如我在战前写的最后一封信是给您的，我祈求上帝保佑，让我能活着在战后写完这封信。以上就是霍雷肖·纳尔逊海军上将写的一封信。它写于 1805 年 10 月 19 日，也就是他与命运进行决定性会面的两天前，这是英国历法中伟大的日子之一，汤姆，这是拿破仑战争中最宏大的海战——特拉法尔加海战的日子。那么艾玛，艾玛是谁？艾玛是纳尔逊的情妇，汉密尔顿夫人。
And Horatia, who he also mentions in that letter, is a four-year-old girl that he had always pretended, was adopted, but in truth was his daughter by Emma Lady Hamilton. And in HMS victory, his flagship at the Battle of Trafalgar, he had their portraits in his cabin. They were his most precious possessions. But two days on from his writing of that letter, so the morning of the 21st of October,
而他在信中提到的霍拉蒂亚，是一个四岁的小女孩，他一直假装她是领养的，但实际上她是他在艾玛·汉密尔顿夫人那里所生的女儿。在特拉法尔加海战中，他的旗舰“胜利号”上，他的船舱里挂着她们的肖像。她们是他最珍贵的财产。但在他写下那封信的两天后，也就是 10 月 21 日的早晨，
they had been stored away with all the other effects that he had in his cabin for safety. And that is because by this point, the French and Spanish fleet had come out from their harbour and lay 10 miles away off Cape Trafalgar in south of Spain. And at 6.22 a.m. on the 21st of October 1805, Nelson gives the signal to his own fleet, prepare for battle. And slowly, slowly, slowly, slowly, the British fleet, with Nelson's own ship, HMS Victory at its forefront, advances towards the French and Spanish battle line, and it does so at no more than a walking pace, two to three miles an hour. And so people may be wondering, what was uppermost in Nelson's mind at this point? We know, because as victory is beginning her advance towards the line of battle,
为了安全起见，它们已经被收进了他船舱里的所有其他物品中。这是因为此时，法国和西班牙舰队已经从港口出来，停泊在西班牙南部特拉法尔加角外 10 英里处。1805 年 10 月 21 日上午 6 点 22 分，纳尔逊向自己的舰队发出信号：准备战斗。慢慢地，慢慢地，英国舰队以纳尔逊的旗舰“胜利号”为先导，向法西联军的战线推进，速度不超过步行速度，每小时两到三英里。所以人们可能会好奇，此时纳尔逊脑海中最重要的事情是什么？我们知道，因为当“胜利号”开始向战线推进时，
Nelson invites the flag captain of his ship, Thomas Hardy, and a second captain, Henry Blackwood, to serve as witnesses to a codicil that he had just made to his will. And I will read it. It's I think one of the most moving documents in the whole of British history. October the 21st, 1,805, then in sight of the combined fleets of France and Spain distant about 10 miles. And obviously, Nelson has placed HMS victory. at the very forefront of the battle. And so he knows there is a very strong possibility. One might almost say probability that he will die in the coming battle. And that being so, his thoughts
纳尔逊邀请了他的旗舰船长托马斯·哈迪和第二位船长亨利·布莱克伍德，作为他刚刚立下的遗嘱附录的见证人。我要读一下。我认为这是整个英国历史上最感人的文件之一。1805 年 10 月 21 日，当时在视线范围内可以看到法国和西班牙的联合舰队，距离约 10 英里。显然，纳尔逊将“胜利号”置于战斗的最前线。所以他知道有非常大的可能性，甚至可以说概率，他会在即将到来的战斗中牺牲。既然如此，他的思绪
are all of Lady Hamilton. And he writes in this will, therefore, that he leaves her, my quote, a legacy to my king and country that they will give her an ample provision to maintain her rank in life. I also leave to the beneficence of my country my adopted daughter Horatia Nelson Thompson and I desire she will use in future the name of Nelson only These are the only favours I ask of my king and country at this moment When I am going to fight their battle Right, very moving Tom Now we have of course done the Battle of Trafalgar before
全都在汉密尔顿夫人身上。因此，他在遗嘱中写道，他留给她，引用我的话，“作为我给国王和国家的遗产，希望他们能给她提供充足的保障，以维持她的生活地位。我也将我领养的女儿霍拉蒂亚·纳尔逊·汤普森托付给国家的仁慈，我希望她将来只使用纳尔逊这个名字。这是我此刻向我的国王和国家请求的唯一恩惠，当我即将为他们而战时。”好的，非常感人，汤姆。现在我们当然以前做过特拉法尔加海战，
And it is one of the best known stories in all British history So most of our listeners, I am guessing, will know what happened to Nelson at Trafalgar. That was a mighty series, a mighty trilogy that we did about Trafalgar, wasn't it? Three hours on Trafalgar, we felt there was so much more to say, didn't we? So much more. In fact, I think we should do the Battle of Trafalgar, maybe once every two years. At least. And we will be doing so, won't we, in what, kind of two and a half weeks?
这是英国历史上最著名的故事之一。所以我猜我们的大多数听众都会知道纳尔逊在特拉法尔加发生了什么。那是一个宏大的系列，我们制作的关于特拉法尔加的宏大三部曲，不是吗？关于特拉法尔加的三个小时，我们觉得还有很多话要说，不是吗？还有很多。事实上，我认为我们应该每两年做一次特拉法尔加海战。至少。我们将会这样做，不是吗，在大约两周半之后？
because we will be resuming our series on the life of Horatio Nelson, which we left, he just won the Battle of the Nile. And in the final episode of that, we will be returning to Trafalgar and following the course of the battle through the eyes of Nelson himself. But first, Dominic, Emma Hamilton. So Emma Hamilton is a very well-known name, even to people who are not massively familiar with society beauties of the 1790s. so what's made her famous is I suppose her association with Nelson
因为我们将恢复关于霍雷肖·纳尔逊生平的系列节目，我们上次讲到他刚刚赢得了尼罗河海战。在最后一集中，我们将回到特拉法尔加，通过纳尔逊本人的视角来追踪战斗的进程。但首先，多米尼克，艾玛·汉密尔顿。所以艾玛·汉密尔顿是一个非常响亮的名字，即使是对 1790 年代的社交名媛不太熟悉的人也知道。那么是什么让她出名呢？我想是她与纳尔逊的联系，
but I guess the question is what is it about her specifically that makes her so compelling to Britain's greatest naval hero what is it about it that means that he's thinking about her even as he sails into battle and why is he's advancing towards the French and the Spanish guns and his final moments on earth why is he so anxious about what will happen to her after he is dead I thought we could try and answer those questions today and do an episode focused on the life of Lady Hamilton as she becomes up until her meeting with Nelson. I think her story is an amazing one, fully merits its own episode.
但我猜问题在于，她身上究竟有什么特质让她对英国最伟大的海军英雄如此具有吸引力？是什么让她即使在驶向战场时也在想念她？为什么当他向法国和西班牙的炮火推进，在他生命中的最后时刻，他会如此焦虑她死后会发生什么？我想今天我们可以试着回答这些问题，做一期专注于汉密尔顿夫人生活直到她遇见纳尔逊之前的节目。我认为她的故事非常精彩，完全值得单独做一期。
And I guess for two principal reasons, you said that she's best known for her relationship with Nelson, and that's undoubtedly true. But she's absolutely no appendage of Nelson, because already when they begin, their affair. She's probably the most celebrated non-royal woman in Europe. I mean, she has a kind of Europe-wide reputation. And for various reasons, so to a really astonishing degree, and bearing in mind that, you know, the invention of Daguerre types of photography still lie several decades in the future at this point, she has one of the most recognizable faces of the age for reasons that we will come to. She is famously beautiful, but she is famous as well for what she termed her attitudes. And these were very distinctive, very original performances which were
我想主要有两个原因。你说她最出名的是她与纳尔逊的关系，这无疑是真的。但她绝不是纳尔逊的附庸，因为在他们开始恋情时，她可能已经是欧洲最著名的非皇室女性了。我的意思是，她有一种全欧洲范围内的声誉。而且由于各种原因，程度非常惊人。考虑到在这一点上，达盖尔摄影法的发明还要再过几十年，她拥有那个时代最容易辨认的面孔之一，原因我们稍后会提到。她不仅以美貌著称，还以她所谓的“姿态”（attitudes）而闻名。这些是非常独特、非常有创意的表演，
designed to bring to life for observers, scenes from classical art. So you could imagine maybe a kind of an image on a Greek vase being brought to life. And she does this so vividly, with such a sense of authenticity that people who witness it are completely stupefied. I've always kind of read this and thought, well, you know, what was she doing? I mean, it sounds a bit like charades or something. It does. It sounds bonkers. But I think when you look into it, you get the sense that people are witnessing something that they had thought impossible. I mean, among the kind of probably the most famous person who witnesses this is the greatest intellectual of the age, Gerta, the great German writer.
旨在为观察者重现古典艺术场景。你可以想象希腊花瓶上的某种形象被赋予了生命。她表现得如此生动，具有如此强烈的真实感，以至于目睹它的人完全惊呆了。我一直读到这里时都在想，她到底在做什么？听起来有点像猜谜游戏之类的。确实。听起来很疯狂。但我认为当你深入研究时，你会感觉到人们正在目睹他们认为不可能的事情。我的意思是，在目睹这一幕的最著名的人中，可能包括那个时代最伟大的知识分子，伟大的德国作家歌德。
And he describes Emma's performance. she lets down her hair and with a few shawls gives so much variety to her poses, gestures, expressions, etc. That the spectator can hardly believe his eyes. I mean, it doesn't sound that incredible to us. But I think that what he is describing is a sense of astonishment that prefigures by a century the astonishment that people felt watching cinematography for the first time. So in other words, seeing a frozen image come to life, that is Emma's skill.
他描述了艾玛的表演：她披散下头发，用几条披肩为她的姿势、手势、表情等增添了如此多的变化，以至于观众几乎不敢相信自己的眼睛。我的意思是，这对我们来说听起来并不那么不可思议。但我认为他所描述的是一种震惊感，这种震惊感比电影摄影术早了一个世纪，人们第一次观看电影时感受到的那种震惊。换句话说，看到一个静止的图像活了过来，这就是艾玛的技巧。
And I think it suggests something of what made Emma so remarkable a figure is that she is like a kind of 20th century silent movie star on an 18th century stage. So she's kind of Lillian Gish or Greta Garboe, Avant La Lettre. And I think when you see her in those terms, you can understand why her attitudes have the kind of impact that they do. So a lot of people may be a tiny bit skeptical about this. And Tom, I have to admit, I was quite skeptical and I read about. Emma Hamilton's attitudes, because I thought they sounded remarkably similar to charades.
我认为这表明了艾玛之所以成为如此非凡的人物，是因为她就像 18 世纪舞台上的 20 世纪默片明星。所以她有点像莉莲·吉什或葛丽泰·嘉宝，在那个时代之前。我认为当你从这些角度看她时，你就能理解为什么她的“姿态”会产生那样的影响。所以很多人可能对此有一点点怀疑。汤姆，我必须承认，我读到艾玛·汉密尔顿的“姿态”时也相当怀疑，因为我觉得它们听起来和猜谜游戏非常相似。
But you're very evangelical about this, aren't you? You think that this is a kind of prefiguring of modernity. Again and again, you read people saying from Gerta and people who are incredibly knowledgeable. Again and again, they are stupefied. And I think what they again and again emphasize is the sense that something that they had always thought of as stationary, so a statue, an image on a vase, is being brought to life for them. And it is being done through something about Emma's ability to turn the static into motion and emotion that they find incredible. And obviously, there is no cinematography, so we can't witness it. But we just have to rely on the sense of superfaction that people felt when watching it. And I think take on trust that Gertr and everybody else, they're not completely mad.
但你对此非常热衷，不是吗？你认为这是一种现代性的预兆。你一次又一次地读到人们说，从歌德到那些知识渊博的人，他们一次又一次地感到震惊。我认为他们反复强调的是一种感觉，即他们一直认为静止的东西——比如雕像、花瓶上的图像——正在为他们活过来。这是通过艾玛将静态转化为动态和情感的能力来实现的，他们觉得这不可思议。显然，没有电影摄影术，所以我们无法亲眼目睹。但我们只能相信人们在观看时感受到的那种震惊感，并相信歌德和其他所有人并不是完全疯了。
They're not just watching charades, I think. Well, we'll come back to the charade. That's a Freudian slip. We'll come back to the attitudes later on. But there's a political side to Emma, right? She's an important kind of political person. Yeah. So in his codicil that he's writing on the morning of Trafalgar,
他们不仅仅是在看猜谜游戏，我想。好吧，我们会回到猜谜游戏。那是一个弗洛伊德式的口误。我们稍后再回到“姿态”。但艾玛身上有政治的一面，对吧？她是一个重要的政治人物。是的。所以在他写于特拉法尔加早晨的附录中，
Nelson praises Emma as a kind of great British patriot who has done her country noble service, just as Nelson himself, of course, has done. She becomes the wife of the British envoy to Naples, so William Hamilton. So that's where she gets her title and name. And while she's there, she has become the confidant of Maria Carolina, Habsburg, the Queen, and a very formidable
纳尔逊称赞艾玛是一位伟大的英国爱国者，她为国家做出了高尚的服务，正如纳尔逊本人所做的那样。她成为了英国驻那不勒斯公使威廉·汉密尔顿的妻子。这就是她获得头衔和名字的由来。当她在那里时，她成为了哈布斯堡王朝的玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜王后的知己，而王后本身也是一位非常令人生畏的
figure in her own right. And Emma exploits this friendship for Britain's benefit. And Nelson in his codicil specifically praises, and I quote, Lady Hamilton's influence with the Queen of Naples. Now, whether that's entirely for good, we will be discussing in our next episode. Yes, because Nelson's relationship with the Queen of Naples, which will come to next week, It turns out to be probably the most controversial element of this entire career. However, from the point of view of Emma significant, this is a woman who is admired by philosophers. She's intimate with queens. So she has a kind of glamour, I think, that fuses very potently with Nelson's own.
人物。艾玛利用这种友谊为英国谋取利益。纳尔逊在附录中特别称赞了，我引用，“汉密尔顿夫人对那不勒斯王后的影响力”。至于这是否完全是好事，我们将在下一集中讨论。是的，因为纳尔逊与那不勒斯王后的关系，我们下周会讲到，结果证明这可能是他整个职业生涯中最具争议的因素。然而，从艾玛的重要性来看，这是一位受到哲学家钦佩的女性。她与王后关系密切。所以她有一种魅力，我认为，这种魅力与纳尔逊本人的魅力非常有力地融合在一起。
And I think that's why she's so celebrated as a mistress, as an enumerator. And in fact, the moment they begin their affair and throughout their relationship and long after both of them are dead, people compare them to one couple from history more than any other, and that is Antony and Cleopatra. Well, there are loads of cartoons, aren't there? So when they go back to England later on, there are loads of cartoons produced showing, I have to say, quite disobliging cartoons, showing Emma as a kind of an enormous Cleopatra. But we should come to this, I guess. And when people mean that comparison, they don't mean it kindly. They don't mean, oh, you're a woman who is navigated through difficult seas and actually has kept her head above water and all this.
我认为这就是为什么她作为情妇、作为枚举者如此出名。事实上，从他们开始恋情的那一刻起，以及在他们整个关系期间，甚至在他们两人去世很久之后，人们将他们与历史上的任何一对情侣相比，那对情侣就是安东尼和克利奥帕特拉。好吧，有很多漫画，不是吗？所以当他们后来回到英国时，制作了大量的漫画，我必须说，相当不客气的漫画，把艾玛描绘成一个巨大的克利奥帕特拉。但我猜我们应该谈谈这个。当人们进行这种比较时，他们并不是善意的。他们不是说，哦，你是一个在困难海域中航行并实际上保持头脑清醒的女性，诸如此类。
They mean, you're a bit of a... I mean, Livitons will forgive me for paraphrasing, you're a bit of a strumpet, as Cleopatra was. I don't know that's not right, but it's what people say. And also Cleopatra seduces Anthony from his duty as a great warrior, which I think people also say about Emma that she's seducing Nelson from his... responsibility to go out and defeat the French in naval battles. And I think the reason why it's so easy for cartoonists and satirists and indeed people throughout high society to sneer at Lady Hamilton
他们的意思是，你有点……我的意思是，利维顿人会原谅我的转述，你有点像个荡妇，就像克利奥帕特拉一样。我不知道那是否正确，但这就是人们所说的。而且克利奥帕特拉诱惑安东尼背离了他作为伟大战士的职责，我想人们也这样评价艾玛，说她诱惑纳尔逊背离了他……去击败法国海军的责任。我认为漫画家和讽刺作家，甚至整个上流社会的人之所以如此容易嘲笑汉密尔顿夫人
as a strumpet is because she is not an aristocrat. She is not well-bred in the slightest. I mean, the absolute opposite. So she is born, not Emma, not Lady Hamilton. She is born Amy Lyon, and she was born into absolutely desperate poverty. And in her time, in her childhood, growing up, she had scrubbed floors. She had sold her body for scraps of food. She emerged from the absolute depths of the emerging industrial society of late 18th century Britain. Right. Well, she's, I mean, this is your, you know, to be your argument, isn't it?
是一个荡妇，是因为她不是贵族。她一点也不出身名门。我的意思是，完全相反。所以她出生时不是艾玛，不是汉密尔顿夫人。她出生时叫艾米·里昂，出生在绝对绝望的贫困中。在她成长的童年时代，她擦过地板。她为了碎屑食物出卖过自己的身体。她从 18 世纪末英国新兴工业社会的绝对底层走出来。好的。好吧，她是，我的意思是，这是你的论点，不是吗？
Actually, people always see Emma Hamilton as a monster, but it would be better to see her, you're going to argue, as not just a victim, I suppose, that's the wrong way of putting it, but as a survivor, as a fighter who's somebody who makes her own way, and then becomes the victim of snobbery for having done so. That's about the long and short of it, isn't it? She is absolutely a fighter, and I think there's no doubt that that's kind of a massive part of what Nelson admired in her. But also, you can see why he's so nervous for her fate on the eve of Trafalgar, because without him, what will become of her. This kind of rags to riches and then perhaps riches back to rags, story is the second reason
实际上，人们总是把艾玛·汉密尔顿看作一个怪物，但你打算争辩说，最好把她看作不仅仅是一个受害者，我想那是错误的说法，而是一个幸存者，一个斗士，一个靠自己闯出一条路，然后因为这样做而成为势利眼受害者的人。这就是事情的来龙去脉，不是吗？她绝对是一个斗士，我认为毫无疑问，这是纳尔逊钦佩她的很大一部分原因。但你也可以看出为什么他在特拉法尔加前夕对她的命运如此紧张，因为没有他，她会怎么样。这种从贫民窟到富贵，然后可能又从富贵回到贫民窟的故事，是讲述她生平故事的第二个原因，
for telling the story of her life because it is, I mean, it's like a novel. Right. It's kind of a cross between, you know, it fuses all of a twist with vanity fair. But I think also it's impossible to tell her story and also think of certainly a couple of obvious 20th century icons, women who capitalized on an age of mass media. to haul themselves up as Emma did from kind of terrible grinding poverty. And we've covered two of them, Marilyn and Evita. And again, I, you know, I compared Emma to a silent movie star.
因为它，我的意思是，它就像一部小说。对。它有点像《雾都孤儿》与《名利场》的结合体。但我认为，讲述她的故事，同时想到 20 世纪的几个明显偶像，那些利用大众媒体时代将自己从可怕的贫困中拉出来的女性，也是不可能的。我们已经讲过其中两个，玛丽莲和艾薇塔。我再次将艾玛比作默片明星。
She is a trailblazer as well for women who are able to use mass media in an industrial age to promote themselves and to kind of escape the slums. So I would say that she's probably the first great female celebrity of the, emerging industrial age. Do you know what she is? This is an excellent observation that Theo has made. She is the link between the lives of Marilyn and Evita in the modern world and a great friend of the rest is history, Huang Jeannie, who is, if you remember, on the other side
她也是那些能够利用工业时代的大众媒体来提升自己并逃离贫民窟的女性的先驱。所以我认为她可能是新兴工业时代第一位伟大的女性名人。你知道她是什么吗？这是西奥提出的一个极好的观察。她是现代世界玛丽莲和艾薇塔的生活与《历史的余味》的一位伟大朋友——黄珍妮之间的联系，如果你还记得的话，她在世界的另一端，
of the world, Korea's greatest courtisan-turned poet. That's an interesting historical observation there from Theo. Don't underestimate Thea's A, knowledge of the rest is history, and B, knowledge of Korean history. Yeah. Right, let's get back to Britain, to Emma and her story. So she comes of age in a world that has been absolutely transformed by the Industrial Revolution, doesn't she? So she comes from the northwest of England.
是韩国最伟大的艺伎转型的诗人。这是西奥提出的一个有趣的史学观察。不要低估西奥对《历史的余味》的了解，以及对韩国历史的了解。是的。好吧，让我们回到英国，回到艾玛和她的故事。她在被工业革命彻底改变的世界中成年，不是吗？所以她来自英格兰西北部。
She's born on the Wirral Peninsula, which is just across the river from Liverpool. And she could have been destroyed by the advent of industrial modernity, couldn't she? Yeah. So the kind of the process of industrialisation, that she ultimately turns to her own ends. I mean, this is at its most destructive. It's pretty much the kind of the birth pangs of industrialisation. And when she's born on the 26th of April, 1765,
她出生在威勒尔半岛，就在利物浦河对岸。她本可能被工业现代性的到来所摧毁，不是吗？是的。工业化的过程，她最终将其转化为自己的目的。我的意思是，这是在它最具破坏性的时候。这几乎是工业化的阵痛。当她于 1765 年 4 月 26 日出生时，
a great seam of coal has only just been discovered, kind of running below the Wirral. And the place she's born, it's a village called Ness, which today I gather is a very pleasant commuter village with a botanic garden next to it. But back then, and I'm quoting here, Kate Williams in her fantastic biography of Emma Hamilton. England's mistress, the infamous life of Emma Hamilton. Oh, TV's Kate Williams. TV's Kate's Kate wrote her PhD on Emma Hamilton Williams.
一条巨大的煤层才刚刚被发现，就在威勒尔下方。她出生的那个地方，是一个叫内斯（Ness）的村庄，据我所知，今天是一个非常宜人的通勤村，旁边有一个植物园。但在那时，我引用凯特·威廉姆斯那本关于艾玛·汉密尔顿的精彩传记，《英国的情妇：艾玛·汉密尔顿臭名昭著的一生》。哦，电视名人凯特·威廉姆斯。电视名人凯特写了关于艾玛·汉密尔顿的博士论文。
She describes Ness back in 1765 as a ramshackle huddle of 30 or so miners hovels set in scrubby, stony, infertile land. Her father, Henry Lyon, is the blacksmith for the coal mine. And her mother, Mary Kid is an exceedingly pretty girl from Hardin. And this is a village near Chester. So it's about 12 miles away from Ness. Again, now, very attractive. I looked it up and it was named in 2012 by the Sunday Times as one of the best places to live. But back in the 18th century, it was so dead end and boring that Mary had run away from it to join a coal mine. But you know who lived in Harden, Tom? Who? Gladstone. And Gladstone would very much have enjoyed Emma Hamilton's attitudes, but he then would have flagellated himself afterwards.
她描述了 1765 年的内斯，是一个由 30 多个矿工棚屋组成的破烂不堪的聚落，坐落在贫瘠、多石、不肥沃的土地上。她的父亲亨利·里昂是煤矿的铁匠。她的母亲玛丽·基德是一个来自哈登（Hardin）的极其漂亮的女孩。这是一个靠近切斯特的村庄。所以距离内斯大约 12 英里。同样，现在非常吸引人。我查了一下，它在 2012 年被《星期日泰晤士报》评为最适合居住的地方之一。但在 18 世纪，它是一个死胡同，非常无聊，以至于玛丽逃离了那里去加入一个煤矿。但你知道谁住在哈登吗，汤姆？谁？格莱斯顿。格莱斯顿会非常喜欢艾玛·汉密尔顿的“姿态”，但他之后会鞭笞自己。
He certainly would. Because there is, and this is an important part of the story, there is a big house just outside Hardin. Yeah. So Hardin is a village from Old England with a big house and, you know, grateful villagers. And Ness is a place where the process of industrialisation is kicking in very, very violently. And so for Mary, her move to Ness turns out not entirely to be a wise one. A marriage to Henry seems to have been forced on her by a pregnancy. And as the wife of a minor, I mean, her life is not going to be a pleasant one at all. It's going to kind of be relentless drudgery. Many wives of minors, they're kind of beaten, whatever. So we don't know whether that happened with Henry, but I mean, it's a possibility. But then just a few weeks
他肯定会。因为有一个，这是故事的重要部分，哈登外面有一座大房子。是的。所以哈登是一个来自旧英格兰的村庄，有大房子和感激的村民。而内斯是一个工业化进程非常、非常猛烈地进行的地方。所以对玛丽来说，她搬到内斯结果并不完全是明智之举。与亨利的婚姻似乎是因为怀孕而被迫的。作为一名矿工的妻子，我的意思是，她的生活一点也不愉快。那将是一种无情的苦役。许多矿工的妻子，她们被殴打，等等。所以我们不知道亨利是否发生了这种情况，但我的意思是，这是一种可能性。但就在艾米出生几周后，
after Emery's born, Henry dies. And the circumstances are mysterious. Emma's mother and Emma herself always very pointedly keep quiet about her father. They don't talk about how he died. And so this kind of speculation, did he drink himself to death? Did he die in a brawl? Did he commit suicide, perhaps? I mean, we just don't know. So on one level, you know, this is a disaster for the little baby Amy.
亨利去世了。情况很神秘。艾玛的母亲和艾玛本人总是非常刻意地对她的父亲保持沉默。她们不谈论他是怎么死的。所以这种猜测，他是酗酒而死吗？他是在斗殴中死去的吗？他可能是自杀吗？我的意思是，我们只是不知道。所以在一个层面上，你知道，这对小婴儿艾米来说是一场灾难。
You know, she's been deprived of the potential breadwinner in the family. But I think on another, actually, it spells a certain measure of freedom because it liberates Mary to escape the life of a worker's wife in an industrial slum, returned to her native village, worked there in the family house. For Mary, it's endless chores. But Amy seems to have kind of grown up fairly unburdened by domestic responsibilities, I think.
你知道，她失去了家庭中潜在的养家糊口的人。但我认为在另一个层面上，实际上，它意味着一定程度的自由，因为它解放了玛丽，让她逃离了工业贫民窟中工人妻子的生活，回到了她的家乡，在家庭住宅里工作。对玛丽来说，那是无尽的杂务。但艾米似乎在成长过程中相当不受家庭责任的负担，我想。
So later in life, she described her childhood as wild and thoughtless. And what's also striking, again, to quote Kate Williams, is that she grows up strikingly statuesque. So Kate writes, she was tall, strong and beautiful with a thick mane of hair and strong white teeth. She had sparkling eyes, clear skin, voluptuous good health and bounding energy. And this is all the more striking because her childhood was marked by repeated kind of famines, smallpox epidemics. But Emma is, you know, very clearly not a girl who's been stunted by rickets or pocked with sores and spots.
所以后来在生活中，她形容自己的童年是狂野和轻率的。同样引人注目的是，再次引用凯特·威廉姆斯的话，她长得非常高大。所以凯特写道，她身材高大、强壮、美丽，有一头浓密的头发和强壮的白牙。她有闪亮的眼睛、清透的皮肤、丰满的健康和充沛的精力。这更令人震惊，因为她的童年标志着反复的饥荒、天花流行。但艾玛，你知道，显然不是一个因佝偻病而发育迟缓或满脸疮疤的女孩。
She also seems to have learned kind of very cursory reading and writing skills. But, I mean, cursory is better than nothing, which is what probably most girls of her standing would have had. Yeah. And so, the Kate Williams' explanation for this is that perhaps Emma's mother, Mary, was having an affair with someone up in the local big house. So she writes, somehow Mary found money that protected Emma from the worst of village hardship and helped her grow into a beauty. Well, hold on. There's no evidence for that, right? I mean, the only evidence is the fact that Amy, who becomes, Emma is not kind of stunted and unable to read and write. And she has reading and writing, yeah. Right.
她似乎也学到了一些非常粗浅的读写技能。但是，我的意思是，粗浅总比没有好，这可能是大多数她那个地位的女孩所拥有的。是的。所以，凯特·威廉姆斯的解释是，也许艾玛的母亲玛丽与当地大房子里的某个人有染。所以她写道，玛丽不知怎么找到了钱，保护了艾玛免受村庄最严重的苦难，并帮助她成长为一个美人。等等。没有证据，对吧？我的意思是，唯一的证据是艾米，也就是后来的艾玛，没有发育迟缓，也没有读写能力。她有读写能力，是的。对。
But if that's true, then that would be a model. Then the young Amy, stroke, Emma, would see that as a model to follow, no, would draw the conclusion that actually, you know, trading on her physical charms was the way to get social and kind of cultural advancement, which would make sense, given what she later chooses to do. Yeah. And I think also what encourages her to be ambitious. is probably her kind of fleeting and disastrous experience of the career that was most readily open to working class girls, which is to go into domestic service.
但如果那是真的，那将是一个榜样。那么年轻的艾米，也就是艾玛，会把那看作一个效仿的榜样，不，会得出结论说，实际上，你知道，利用她的身体魅力是获得社会和文化进步的方式，考虑到她后来选择做的事情，这说得通。是的。而且我认为也鼓励她有野心。可能是她那种短暂而灾难性的职业经历，这是最容易向工人阶级女孩开放的职业，那就是去从事家政服务。
Yeah. So Emma does work in the big house at Harden. So in 1777, when she's 12 years old, she goes there for a few months, and then she gets sacked, basically, I think, because she's completely hopeless at housework. Okay. It's not her, not her vibe at all. and then the following autumn she travels to London to the big smoke and again she secures a job as a house made there and again she gets sacked and this time it's for staying out late with a friend so kind of very teenage behaviour clearly she's she's not cut out to be a maid of all work but what that experience does is to open her eyes in a way that she wouldn't have done if she just stayed in her village to the kind of entire dimensions of luxury and leisure and fine living and the kind of beautiful clothes and the plentiful food that it can provide you with. And I think it gives her a desire to have that for herself. But the question,
是的。所以艾玛确实在哈登的大房子里工作过。所以 1777 年，当她 12 岁时，她在那里待了几个月，然后她被解雇了，基本上，我想是因为她完全不擅长家务。好的。那不是她，不是她的风格。然后第二年秋天，她前往伦敦，那个大烟囱，她再次在那里找到了一份女佣的工作，然后她又被解雇了，这次是因为她和朋友待得太晚了——所以是一种非常青少年的行为，显然她不是做杂务女佣的料，但那种经历确实以一种她如果一直待在村子里就不会有的方式打开了她的眼界，看到了奢侈、休闲和美好生活的整个维度，以及它能为你提供的漂亮衣服和充足的食物。我认为这给了她为自己拥有这些东西的渴望。但问题是，
of course, she's 13 years old. She's penniless. She's an out-of-towner provincial in London. She doesn't have a patron. She doesn't have anything beyond the most rudimentary education. And so the question then is, how is she going to fulfill her dreams? Right, but obviously if her mother has had an affair with somebody in the big house, that would give her an example to follow. So for one thing, she has a show business side to her, and that's a question of temperaments as much as anything, isn't it? She loves London is the place of public entertainment, theatres, you know, dances, pleasure gardens and so on, and clearly by temperament. That's why she gets stuck from her job because she's been out late at a fair. Right.
当然，她 13 岁。她身无分文。她是伦敦的外地人。她没有赞助人。她除了最基础的教育外什么都没有。所以问题是，她将如何实现她的梦想？对，但显然如果她的母亲与大房子里的某个人有染，那会给她一个效仿的榜样。所以一方面，她有演艺的一面，这与其说是气质问题，不如说是其他问题，不是吗？她热爱伦敦，那是公共娱乐、剧院、你知道、舞蹈、游乐花园等等的地方，显然从气质上讲。这就是她被解雇的原因，因为她因为去参加集会而待得太晚了。对。
She's very keen on kind of all the entertainments that London has to provide. Yeah. And which London probably more than anywhere else in the face of the planet at that time provides in plentiful numbers. Yeah. So she's a great one for the smell of the grease paint and all that. Right. But then the other thing, which is, let's say, an asset that a lot of girls would not have had is her physical appearance. So everything we ever read about her says she's very tall.
她非常热衷于伦敦所能提供的各种娱乐活动。是的。而且伦敦在当时地球上提供的娱乐活动可能比任何地方都多。是的。所以她非常喜欢油彩的味道等等。对。但另一件事，也就是，让我们说，许多女孩不会拥有的资产是她的外表。所以我们读到的关于她的一切都说她非常高。
She's extremely striking. Everybody says, you know, she's got brilliant hair. You know, you don't forget her. So at this point, what is she? 12, 13 years old? 13. 13 years old. And this is an age where a 13-year-old girl would already have been prey to predatory men, do you think?
她非常引人注目。每个人都说，你知道，她有一头漂亮的头发。你知道，你不会忘记她。所以此时，她几岁？12、13 岁？13。13 岁。这是一个 13 岁的女孩本已成为掠夺性男人的猎物的时代，你认为呢？
There's no legal age of consent. You know, she's been working as a housemaid alone in rooms. I would suspect that absolutely by this point she has suffered, you know, a fair degree of sexual harassment, maybe even abuse. She turns it to her advantage, I think, by feeling a sense of confidence in her ability to turn men's heads. Right. And kind of confident that she can turn it to her own ends. And that being so, she takes the very bold and conscious decision when she's sacked from her post as a housemaid to head to London's. most glamorous, most notorious, most exciting playground. And this is a place where women have
没有法定同意年龄。你知道，她一直作为女佣独自在房间里工作。我怀疑到这一点时，她绝对遭受了相当程度的性骚扰，甚至可能是虐待。我认为她通过对自己吸引男人注意力的能力的自信，将其转化为自己的优势。对。而且自信她可以将其转化为自己的目的。既然如此，当她被解雇时，她做出了非常大胆和自觉的决定，前往伦敦最迷人、最臭名昭著、最令人兴奋的游乐场。这是一个女性长期以来
long outnumbered men. And it's a great centre of pleasure called Covent Garden. Right. And this was a piazza that had been designed back in the 1630s by the great architect Inigo Jones. It's been ringed by stately streets. But beyond them, there's a kind of entire donut of slums. And probably the most notorious of these is the rookery of St. Giles. And this is where Hogarth, in his great satirical cartoon, sets Gin Lane. So, you know, drunk mothers, babies falling to their doom down steps, absolute scenes of squalor. I mean, but satire draws on kind of horrific reality. So what you have in Covent Garden is wealth and squalor, high-brow entertainments and low-brow entertainments, to quote Vic Gattrell, the great historian of Georgian culture,
超过男性的地方。这是一个被称为考文特花园（Covent Garden）的巨大娱乐中心。对。这是一个由伟大的建筑师伊尼戈·琼斯在 1630 年代设计的广场。它被庄严的街道环绕。但在它们之外，有一圈贫民窟。其中最臭名昭著的可能是圣吉尔斯的贫民窟。这就是霍加斯在他的伟大讽刺漫画中设置“金酒巷”的地方。所以，你知道，醉酒的母亲，婴儿从台阶上掉下来，绝对是肮脏的场景。我的意思是，但讽刺画借鉴了某种可怕的现实。所以你在考文特花园拥有的是财富和肮脏，高雅的娱乐和低俗的娱乐，引用乔治亚文化伟大历史学家维克·加特雷尔的话，
what developed in Covent Garden square half mile in the second half of the century was the world's first creative bohemia. And it is the absolute epicenter of Georgian culture. So you have London's two great theatres, Drury Lane and Covent Garden. You have coffee shops that are filled with writers and playwrights and artists and you have the best shopping in the world. This is where the nation that Napoleon will mock as just shopkeepers. This is where they're really honing their art. Covent Garden offers probably the best shopping in the entire world. But not just shopping, right? Well, I mean, there are lots of things for sale, let's put it like that. Yeah, exactly. So what we might see is a seediness to Covent Garden. It's basically a massive
在世纪下半叶，考文特花园广场半英里内发展起来的是世界上第一个创意波西米亚。它是乔治亚文化的绝对中心。所以你有伦敦的两大剧院，德鲁里巷和考文特花园。你有充满作家、剧作家和艺术家的咖啡店，你有世界上最好的购物场所。这就是拿破仑嘲笑为“店主”的国家。这就是他们真正磨练艺术的地方。考文特花园提供了世界上最好的购物场所。但不仅仅是购物，对吧？好吧，我的意思是，有很多东西在出售，我们就这么说吧。是的，完全正确。所以我们可能会看到考文特花园的肮脏。它基本上是一个巨大的
red light district. And it's full of cut purses and ruffians and streetwalkers and prostitutes. Yeah. And so Kate Williams in her biography of Emma quotes one very excited visitor who says, Covent Garden is the great square of Venus and its perluse are crowded with the practitioners of this goddess. Right. Which is to say, are lots of prostitutes and spanning the entire social range. So you have very high-end brothels, but you also have kind of gin-raddled streetwalkers of the kind that you see in in Gin Lane. The healthier girls even have their own kind of almanac. They have their own guide, which is published annually called Harris's List of Covent Garden Ladies, which gives descriptions
红灯区。它充满了扒手、恶棍、街头游荡者和妓女。是的。所以凯特·威廉姆斯在她的艾玛传记中引用了一位非常兴奋的游客的话，他说：“考文特花园是维纳斯的伟大广场，其周边挤满了这位女神的从业者。”对。也就是说，有很多妓女，涵盖了整个社会阶层。所以你有高端妓院，但你也有你在“金酒巷”中看到的那种喝得烂醉的街头游荡者。健康的女孩甚至有她们自己的年鉴。她们有自己的指南，每年出版，名为《考文特花园女士名单》，其中给出了描述
of the form. So give people a sense. I mean, many of these people would also be actresses, right and they'd also be kind of professional models yeah so there's no you know there's no clear divide between those difference you know you could easily slip from one of those roles into another one yeah so um jill perry um this again describing this milia she says whoring and acting were easily alided right i mean this provides a massive opportunity of course and so for a girl like emma who is beautiful um charismatic high-spirited but also poor provincial, without a support network. Covent Garden provides opportunity, like nowhere else on earth, I mean, massive opportunity, but at the same time, massive danger. And essentially,
关于形式。所以给人们一个概念。我的意思是，这些人中的许多人也会是女演员，对吧，她们也会是某种职业模特，是的，所以没有，你知道，这些差异之间没有明确的界限，你知道，你可以很容易地从这些角色中的一个滑入另一个，是的，所以……吉尔·佩里，再次描述这种环境，她说“卖淫和演戏很容易混淆”，对，我的意思是，这当然提供了巨大的机会，所以对于像艾玛这样美丽、有魅力、高昂精神，但又贫穷、来自外省、没有支持网络的女孩来说，考文特花园提供了地球上任何地方都无法比拟的机会，我的意思是，巨大的机会，但与此同时，巨大的危险。本质上，
what she's embroiling herself in when she heads to Covent Garden is a kind of high-stakes, red-light district version of Pride and Prejudice. Right, because on the one hand, the prize, the goal is to get a patron. I mean, I guess even better would be if she could somehow, persuade somebody very rich and well-connected to marry her. Imagine that. Yeah, but that would be very difficult to imagine. Much more likely is that she'll become a kind of mistress, a kept woman, I suppose.
当她前往考文特花园时，她卷入的是一种高风险、红灯区版本的《傲慢与偏见》。对，因为一方面，奖品，目标是获得一个赞助人。我的意思是，我猜如果她能以某种方式说服某个非常有钱且关系广泛的人娶她，那就更好了。想象一下。是的，但这很难想象。更有可能的是，她会成为某种情妇，一个被包养的女人，我想。
Yeah. The downside is if you don't manage to do that, you know, over time you descend the rungs of the ladder of the ladies of Covengard and so basically in 10 years time, you're the person with no teeth who's just necking loads of gin. Yeah, exactly. And throughout her teens, Emma is constantly kind of swinging between these twin poles. So she gets work at the theatre at Drury Lane, Dominic, where you and I appeared, very excitingly.
是的。缺点是如果你没能做到这一点，你知道，随着时间的推移，你会沿着考文特花园女士的阶梯走下去，所以基本上 10 年后，你就是那个没有牙齿、整天喝金酒的人。是的，完全正确。在她的十几岁时期，艾玛不断地在这些双重极点之间摇摆。所以她在德鲁里巷剧院找到了工作，多米尼克，你和我曾经在那里出现过，非常令人兴奋。
Yeah. And she worked there as a wardrobe assistant. So she's dressing actresses and she gets a chance to study, you know, how they put on a performance. She gets a feel for the theatre. And then she gets made redundant. And this is the lowest point of her life. She's kind of briefly reduced to walking the streets. And this is something that Emma herself never denied.
是的。她在那里担任服装助理。所以她在为女演员穿衣服，她有机会学习，你知道，她们是如何进行表演的。她对剧院有了感觉。然后她被裁员了。这是她一生中最糟糕的时刻。她被短暂地降级到街头游荡。这是艾玛本人从未否认过的事情。
So later in life, she said, I own through distress. My virtue was vanquished. but my sense of virtue was not overcome. She gets jobs in taverns, again, the kind of the boundary between Armade and Tavern in this period is pretty narrow. And then she begins to supplement her work as an artist's model. And her most improbable gig, which is so improbable that there are historians, Vic Gatrol among them, who doubt should ever happen. But I think Kate Williams makes the case very convincingly that it did. She ends up working for a notorious quack doctor called Dr. James Graham,
所以后来在生活中，她说：“我承认由于困境，我的贞操被征服了，但我的贞操感并没有被克服。”她在酒馆里找工作，同样，在这个时期，女佣和酒馆之间的界限非常狭窄。然后她开始补充她作为艺术家模特的工作。她最不可思议的演出，这太不可思议了，以至于有历史学家，包括维克·加特雷尔，怀疑它是否发生过。但我认为凯特·威廉姆斯非常有说服力地证明了它确实发生了。她最终为一位臭名昭著的江湖医生工作，名叫詹姆斯·格雷厄姆医生，
who runs what he called a Temple of Health off the Strand. Oh, I can't believe this didn't happen. I've always believed this did happen. I think it did. Yeah. I think Kate Williams' arguments on the veracity are very convincing. Okay. And also, I want it to have happened.
他在河岸街附近经营着他所谓的“健康神殿”。哦，我不敢相信这没有发生。我一直相信这确实发生了。我想它确实发生了。是的。我认为凯特·威廉姆斯关于真实性的论点非常有说服力。好的。而且，我也希望它发生过。
Right. We go with that. So, so Dr. Graham is, he's a massive enthusiast for electrotherapy. He was actually a kind of an associate of Benjamin Franklin. Um, he loves a mud bath. Um, and again, the kind of satirists always, they love drawing cartoons of enormously fat men being dropped into vats of mud. Um, and to quote Kate Williams, he was a supreme showman and his lectures were extravaganzas featuring explosions, smoke, fireworks, music and to London's utter delight, a phalanx of glamour girls posing in flimsy white dresses. And Emma's
对。我们就这么定。格雷厄姆医生是一位电疗的狂热爱好者。他实际上是本杰明·富兰克林的某种合伙人。嗯，他喜欢泥浴。而且，讽刺作家们总是喜欢画一些巨大的胖子被扔进泥浆桶里的漫画。引用凯特·威廉姆斯的话说，他是一位顶级的表演大师，他的讲座简直就是一场场奢华的演出，充满了爆炸、烟雾、烟花、音乐，还有让伦敦人欣喜若狂的、穿着轻薄白裙摆姿势的魅力女郎方阵。而艾玛的
role was to pose on an absolutely enormous bed dressed in a kind of very skimpy classical style costume and pose as Vestina the rosy goddess of health. And the bed itself is supported by 40 pillars of very finely worked glass. There are pipes that pump out perfume. There are kind of cranks that are operated by people lying under the bed to make the mattress jiggle. And every so often there'll be a kind of jolt of electricity will go through the bed just to keep people on their toes. And hold on, you could pay to go and lie on this bed yourself and not just to lie on the bed, right? You could. You pay £50 a night. That's a lot of money.
角色是躺在一张巨大的床上，穿着一种非常暴露的古典风格服装，扮演健康的玫瑰女神维斯蒂娜。床本身由40根做工精细的玻璃柱支撑。有管道喷出香水。还有一些曲柄由躺在床下的人操作，让床垫晃动。每隔一段时间，就会有一阵电流穿过床，让人们保持警觉。等等，你还可以付钱自己去躺在这张床上，而且不仅仅是躺在床上，对吧？你可以。你每晚支付50英镑。那可是一大笔钱。
You have to be very affluent to do that. Yeah. And essentially, it's meant to be for married couples, but of course it isn't. The Prince Regent inevitably takes his mistresses with him. And Emma's role on the bed, you know, she's not sleeping with the married couples. She's exhibiting the pleasures of the bed. She's showing off what you would look like if you lay on the bed and saying you can be like me and lie on this fantastic bed with the electricity.
你得非常有钱才能那样做。是的。本质上，这应该是为已婚夫妇准备的，但当然不是。摄政王不可避免地带着他的情妇去。艾玛在床上的角色，你知道，她不是和已婚夫妇睡觉。她是在展示这张床的乐趣。她在炫耀如果你躺在床上会是什么样子，并说你可以像我一样，躺在这张带有电流的神奇床上。
And then she gets off and these people get on it. Yeah. Right. Okay. So outside this Temple of Health, Graham has set up naked statues, which are actually so titillating that he ends up being prosecuted for them. And Emma is a kind of living statue. So there perhaps you have a presentiment of the idea
然后她下来，这些人上去。对。好的。那么在这个健康神庙外，格雷厄姆设置了裸体雕像，这些雕像实际上非常撩人，以至于他最终因此被起诉。而艾玛就是一种活的雕像。所以在这里，你也许能预感到
of the attitudes, the idea of a statue coming to life. And her goal is to lie there and look like a goddess, but also to encourage the men to get on and do what they've got to do. And this is probably Emma's big break, because it leads to her being talent spotted at the age of 14 by London's most exclusive and vampiric madam, a woman called Charlotte Hayes, who goes under the suprake of Mrs. Kelly. And her brothel is the classiest in London. It's not in Covent Garden. It's in much more kind of upmarket area of St. James's. Emma is only one of seven or eight girls who works there. Absolutely world away from walking the streets. She has a carriage, all kinds of things. She dresses up in very finely cut, low cut.
关于姿态的想法，关于雕像复活的想法。她的目标是躺在那里，看起来像一位女神，同时也鼓励男人们上去做他们该做的事。这可能是艾玛的重大突破，因为这使她在14岁时被伦敦最高档、最吸血鬼式的鸨母夏洛特·海耶斯发现，她化名为凯利夫人。她的妓院是伦敦最高级的。它不在考文特花园。它在圣詹姆斯区，一个更高档的地方。艾玛只是在那里工作的七八个女孩之一。这与在街上拉客完全是两个世界。她有马车，各种各样的东西。她穿着剪裁精良、低胸的
pink dresses, she will dress as kind of famous actresses. She's never going to be rich for her, because she's pretty much indentured to Mrs. Kelly. So Mrs. Kelly pockets all the winnings, basically. Absolutely, and gets them in debt. You know, she'll kind of feed them drink and then kind of run up a tab. But because the clients are all so rich, I mean, only the absolute kind of the top end of society can afford to go there. Obviously, there's always the hope for the girls in this brothel that they will hit the jackpot. And, you know, Emma can dream of finding a man who will buy her.
粉色裙子，她会打扮成各种著名的女演员。她永远不会富有，因为她几乎被卖身给了凯利夫人。所以凯利夫人基本上把所有的收入都装进了自己的口袋。绝对是这样，而且让她们负债累累。你知道，她会给她们提供酒水，然后记账。但因为客户都非常有钱，我的意思是，只有社会最顶层的人才负担得起去那里。显然，妓院里的女孩们总是希望自己能中大奖。而且，你知道，艾玛可以梦想找到一个能为她赎身的男人。
out. And that in 1781, at which point she is 16, that is the jackpot that Emma does seem to hit in the form of a very hard drinking, hard hunting squire called Sir Harry Beatherston Hawth. At least I think that's how you pronounce it. It ends H-A-U-G-H. Okay. And the question is, Dominic, who is this Mr. Darcy? Well, let's take a break. And then after the break, we can see him emerging, dripping with water from the lake of love. I don't know where I'm going with this analogy. But anyway, it's your commercial break quickly. Yeah, we better get to the break.
在1781年，那时她16岁，那似乎就是艾玛中大奖的时候，对象是一位酗酒、酷爱狩猎的乡绅，名叫哈里·费瑟斯通·豪爵士。至少我认为是这样发音的。结尾是H-A-U-G-H。好的。问题是，多米尼克，这位达西先生是谁？好吧，我们休息一下。休息之后，我们可以看到他从爱之湖中湿漉漉地走出来。我不知道这个比喻要表达什么。但总之，这是你的商业广告时间。是的，我们最好去休息一下。
Goodbye. This episode is brought to you by Uber. Now, do you know that feeling when someone shows up for you when you need it most? We all need that sometimes. And Uber knows it. Uber isn't just a ride or a meal delivered. it's showing up no matter what. Like for your long distance friends, bringing soup when they're sick, sending flowers when
再见。本集由优步赞助。现在，你知道当有人在你最需要的时候出现的那种感觉吗？我们有时都需要那样。优步知道这一点。优步不仅仅是一次乘车或一份外卖，它意味着无论发生什么都会出现。就像为了你的远方朋友，在他们生病时送去汤，在他们情绪低落时送去鲜花。
they're down. When it really matters, whatever it is, you show up. Where there's a will, we're on our way. Uber, on our way. Download the app today. Hey, what shall I do? Good God, what shall I do? I've wrote seven letters and no answer
当真正重要的时候，无论是什么，你都会出现。有志者事竟成，我们在路上。优步，在路上。立即下载应用程序。嘿，我该怎么办？天哪，我该怎么办？我写了七封信，没有回音。
I can't come to town for want of money I've not a farthing to bless myself with and I think my friends looks coolly on me I'm almost mad oh for God's sake tell me what's to become on me oh dear Greville write to me right to me gee adieu and believe me yours forever
我没钱去城里，我连一个铜板都没有，我觉得朋友们对我冷淡。我快疯了，哦，看在上帝的份上，告诉我我该怎么办？哦，亲爱的格雷维尔，写信给我，写信给我，再见，永远相信我是你的。
Emily Hart So that was an archive recording I mean that's actually the only Northwestern accent I can do and it's not even I don't even think it relates to a place But actually what I was trying to do was channel the girl born as Amy Lyon, the woman who had become Emma Hamilton, and who for now was calling herself Emily Hart. So those are her own words in the voice of the co-founder of Goldhanger, Tony Paster.
艾米丽·哈特。那是一段档案录音，我的意思是，那实际上是我唯一能模仿的西北口音，而且我甚至不认为它与某个地方有关。但实际上我试图做的是传达那个出生时叫艾米·里昂的女孩，那个后来成为艾玛·汉密尔顿的女人，当时她自称艾米丽·哈特。所以这些是她自己的话，由Goldhanger的联合创始人托尼·帕斯特配音。
Yeah, and just to say, this is the first time we get to hear her in her own words. Wow. And so I'm glad I've treated them with the sensitivity and respect they deserve. So she's now calling herself Emily Hart. She's saying, what shall I do? And she's in a terrible mess, isn't she? And why is she in such a mess? Because we left before the break.
是的，只想说，这是我们第一次听到她用自己的话说话。哇。所以我很高兴我以她们应得的敏感和尊重对待了这些话。所以她现在自称艾米丽·哈特。她说，我该怎么办？她陷入了可怕的困境，不是吗？为什么她陷入了这样的困境？因为我们在休息前离开了。
Mr. Darcy had entered the story, dripping wet. What's gone wrong? So Harry Featherstone Haw, who is 26 years old. He's the MP for Portsmouth. He's the owner of an absolutely splendid pile in Sussex. He has turned out to be an utter shit. Oh, no. It had not taken Emma long to realise this.
达西先生湿漉漉地进入了故事。出了什么问题？哈里·费瑟斯通·豪爵士，26岁。他是朴茨茅斯的议员。他是萨塞克斯郡一座极其壮丽的宅邸的主人。结果他是个彻头彻尾的混蛋。哦，不。艾玛没花多久就意识到了这一点。
So she has been basically bought out by Sir Harry. takes her to his stately pile, A Park House on the South Downs, and just kind of keeps her there for his own entertainment and the entertainment of all his mates. But that was the plan, no? That was what she wanted. Yeah, it is.
所以她基本上被哈里爵士买断了。他把她带到他那座宏伟的宅邸，南唐斯区的Uppock House，只是把她留在那里供他自己娱乐，也供他所有的伙伴们娱乐。但那不是计划吗？那不是她想要的吗？是的，确实是。
The problem is that he's not really very romantic at all because all he's really into is horses. So, you know, he's MP for Portsmouth. He never once gives a speech because he's always off fox hunting or racing or whatever. And actually, he loves racing so much that there's one female visitor who describes how at Uppock House
问题是他一点也不浪漫，因为他真正感兴趣的只有马。所以，你知道，他是朴茨茅斯的议员。他从来没有发表过演讲，因为他总是去猎狐、赛马什么的。事实上，他非常热爱赛马，有一位女性访客描述了在Uppock House
There are races of all sorts, fine horses, ponies, cart horses, women, men in sacks. He's the kind of guy that Peter the Great probably have got along with quite well. Yeah, definitely. So, Emma, you know, she does her best. She learns to ride, which is an essential skill. And she's given a very tight riding habit, which she adores, like Skittles. Of course. The Great Cortezan.
有各种各样的比赛，好马、小马、驮马、女人、麻袋里的人。他大概是那种彼得大帝会相处得很好的人。是的，绝对是。所以，艾玛，你知道，她尽了最大努力。她学会了骑马，这是一项基本技能。她得到了一套非常紧身的骑马装，她很喜欢，就像斯基特尔斯一样。当然。伟大的交际花。
But I think she's very lonely. and her only real friend is the one man among Sir Harry's coterie who does not enjoy hunting. And all Sahari and his friends, they all find this hilarious, they can't understand it at all. And this is a guy who is very well connected, but relatively by the standards of the aristocracy in Pecunius. He's the second son of the Earl of Warwick and his name is Charles Greville. And that's the Greville who Emma was addressing in her frantic letter. His real passion is for collecting minerals. Like Wilfrid Owen, the poet, the war poet.
但我认为她很孤独。她唯一真正的朋友是哈里爵士圈子里唯一一个不喜欢狩猎的男人。哈里爵士和他的朋友们都觉得这很滑稽，他们根本无法理解。这是一个背景很好，但按贵族标准相对贫困的家伙。他是沃里克伯爵的次子，名叫查尔斯·格雷维尔。那就是艾玛在疯狂的信中称呼的格雷维尔。他真正的热情是收集矿物。就像战争诗人威尔弗雷德·欧文一样。
But since he is often alone with Emma while all the others are out hunting, inevitably they're thrown together and he ends up very besotted by her. Meanwhile, Sir Harry has been behaving exactly as you would expect, a late Georgian squire to behave. he gets Emma pregnant, he throws her out of the house without a penny, and he then refuses to answer her letters. Oh, Sir Harry. And this is why in January 1782, she writes the letter that you quoted to Charles Greville. And her situation is desperate. She's heavily pregnant by this point. She doesn't have any money. But when she writes that letter, you know, she clearly is in desperate straits, but she is also playing a part. It is the tone of kind of high-wrought sentiment. She is deliberately exaggerating to appeal to Greville.
但由于他经常和艾玛单独在一起，而其他人都在外面打猎，他们不可避免地走到了一起，他最终对她非常着迷。与此同时，哈里爵士的行为正如你所预料的那样，一个晚乔治时代的乡绅会有的表现。他让艾玛怀孕了，把她赶出家门，一分钱没给，然后拒绝回信。哦，哈里爵士。这就是为什么在1782年1月，她写了那封你引用的给查尔斯·格雷维尔的信。她的处境很绝望。此时她已怀有身孕。她没有任何钱。但当她写那封信时，你知道，她显然处于绝望的境地，但她也在演戏。这是一种高度激昂的情感基调。她故意夸大其词以吸引格雷维尔。
She's framing it in the tones of a kind of a lady from a novel who has been badly treated. It's an epistory novel. She has been poorly treated by the vicomte or whatever his name is. The Comte de Valmont. Yeah, Valmont in Leisand-Dorges. Actually, it completely works, right? Because he reaches out to her. He does.
她用一种被虐待的小说女主角的口吻来表达。这是一部书信体小说。她受到了子爵或不管他叫什么名字的人的恶劣对待。瓦尔蒙子爵。是的，《危险关系》里的瓦尔蒙。实际上，这完全奏效了，对吧？因为他联系了她。他确实联系了。
Well, he still massively fancies her. Right. So very chivalrously, a few years later, he will describe her as the only woman I ever slept with without having ever had any of my senses offended. And a cleaner, sweeter bedfellow does not exist. Oh, right. So that's high praise indeed. Yeah, high praise. But he imposes very strict terms on Emma. So she has to give up her baby the moment that it's born, handed over to her great grandmother. She has to discard her old name. So no more Amy Lyons. So this is why Emily Hart is then born. She's Mrs. Hart. And she's to have no further dealings with any of her old acquaintances from
嗯，他仍然非常喜欢她。对。所以非常绅士地，几年后，他会形容她是“我唯一一个在没有感到任何感官被冒犯的情况下与之同床的女人。没有比她更干净、更甜美的床伴了。”哦，对。那确实是极高的赞美。是的，极高的赞美。但他对艾玛施加了非常严格的条件。所以她必须在孩子出生时就放弃，交给她的曾祖母。她必须丢弃她的旧名字。所以不再有艾米·里昂。这就是为什么艾米丽·哈特诞生了。她是哈特夫人。她不得再与她以前的任何熟人有任何往来，从
Sir Harry right the way down to her relatives. The only one that she can see is her mother who effectively, from this point on, is employed as her kind of housekeeper. And the one hand, that sounds very harsh, but I suppose Greville would say, I'm cleaning up her situation, and she's going to be much better off. And actually, a lot of her old acquaintances are kind of rapacious madams and stuff, so she's better off without them. Yeah, and Emma, I think, instinctively understands this, that what Greville wants from her isn't just sex, but also, oddly, kind of almost the opposite, a kind of display of chastity and modesty. And so Greville installs her just off the Edgeware Road in the village of Paddington,
哈里爵士一直到她的亲戚。她唯一能见的人是她的母亲，从这一点开始，她实际上被雇佣为她的管家。一方面，这听起来很严厉，但我猜格雷维尔会说，我正在清理她的处境，她会过得更好。事实上，她以前的许多熟人都是贪婪的鸨母之类的，所以没有她们她会更好。是的，我认为艾玛本能地理解这一点，格雷维尔从她身上想要的不仅仅是性，而且奇怪的是，几乎是相反的东西，一种贞洁和谦逊的展示。所以格雷维尔把她安置在帕丁顿村，就在埃奇韦尔路旁边，
which is just a kind of semi-rural outskirt of London at this point. And basically, the role he wants her to play is that of a kind of repentant Magdalene. A sinner has been redeemed. And he seems to have found this titillating in the extreme. so he deliberately kind of moulds her to his tastes. She's to be very, very modest. You know, she's to cast off all the manners of the street. And Emma kind of absorbs this like blotting paper.
在当时这只是伦敦的一个半乡村郊区。基本上，他想让她扮演的角色是一个悔改的抹大拉的马利亚。一个被救赎的罪人。他似乎觉得这极其撩人。所以他故意塑造她以符合他的品味。她要非常非常谦逊。你知道，她要抛弃所有的街头习气。而艾玛像吸墨纸一样吸收了这些。
So it is a kind of education. Well, he's Henry Higgins and she's the lies to do little, to some extent. I think that's exactly the parallel. I mean, there are two ways you can view that. I would say you've taken a stance, which is quite cynical and hostile to gravel. You know, he's doing this because he finds it. He might also have done it because he genuinely likes her and wants to help her. That two are not mutually exclusive.
所以这是一种教育。嗯，他在某种程度上是亨利·希金斯，她是伊莉莎·杜利特尔。我认为这正是平行之处。我的意思是，你可以有两种看法。我会说你采取了一种立场，对格雷维尔相当愤世嫉俗和敌对。你知道，他这样做是因为他觉得这很有趣。他也可能这样做是因为他真心喜欢她并想帮助她。这两者并不相互排斥。
Right. I think both of those things are true. Yeah. He's not doing just out of charity. He wants to make money out of her. And so he does pimper out, not as a prostitute, but as an artist's model. Right. And he kind of basically sells her as a model to the man who is widely regarded by this point
对。我认为这两件事都是真的。是的。他不仅仅是出于慈善。他想从她身上赚钱。所以他确实把她当皮条客推销，不是作为妓女，而是作为艺术家的模特。对。他基本上把她作为模特卖给了当时被广泛认为
as the greatest portrait painter in Britain, even greater than Sir Joshua Reynolds, the founder of the Royal Academy. And this is a man who's very emotional, very troubled, very brilliant, a guy called George Romney. And all his life, he's been looking for his muse, and he finds her in Emma. He becomes absolutely obsessed by her beauty, by her intelligence, by her incredible emotional literacy, her ability to convey through her face and vast numbers of emotions. And again, the way in which she seems like a classical statue come to life. So this is kind of a theme that runs throughout her career. To quote the poet William Haley, who wrote a biography of Romney in 1809, so while Emma was still very much on the scene.
是英国最伟大的肖像画家，甚至比皇家艺术学院的创始人约书亚·雷诺兹爵士还要伟大。这是一个非常情绪化、非常困扰、非常天才的人，名叫乔治·罗姆尼。他一生都在寻找他的缪斯，他在艾玛身上找到了。他完全被她的美貌、她的智慧、她令人难以置信的情感素养、她通过面部传达大量情感的能力所吸引。同样，她看起来像古典雕像复活的方式。所以这是贯穿她职业生涯的一个主题。引用诗人威廉·黑利的话，他在1809年写了罗姆尼的传记，当时艾玛仍然非常活跃。
And he wrote, her features like the language of Shakespeare could exhibit all the feelings of nature and the gradation of every passion with the most fascinating truth and felicity of expression. And that's very much how admirers of her attitudes will also describe her. Right. And it is Romney who paints this woman who he calls his divine essence. Emma over 70 times who makes her famous, or at least her face famous, because even though Romney himself is, he doesn't exhibit paintings and exhibitions. People come to the studio and prints are made of these paintings and basically they go viral. The opportunities for the printing press to reproduce images by this point is kind of expanding all the time. And Emma rides the
他写道：“她的特征就像莎士比亚的语言，能够以最迷人的真实和表达的幸福感展现自然的所有情感和每一种激情的渐变。”这正是她的姿态的崇拜者们也会描述她的方式。对。正是罗姆尼画了这个他称之为“神圣本质”的女人。罗姆尼画了艾玛70多次，这让她出名了，或者至少让她的脸出名了，因为尽管罗姆尼本人并不参加画展。人们来到工作室，这些画作被制作成版画，基本上它们就病毒式传播了。印刷机复制图像的机会在这一点上一直在扩大。而艾玛乘上了
of that wave. And she's exceptional in various ways. I mean, all kinds of reasons why she becomes so successful, but you can list them. She's obviously unbelievably beautiful. And her style of beauty, so she's got an oval face, she's got large eyes, she's got kind of very well-defined lips, thick, urban hair. This absolutely corresponds to the kind of the ideals of beauty of the age. and the way in which she gases directly at the viewer in the way that most models don't. And some of the paintings,
那股浪潮。她在各个方面都很出色。我的意思是，她之所以如此成功有各种各样的原因，但你可以列举出来。她显然美得令人难以置信。她的美貌风格，她有一张椭圆形的脸，大眼睛，轮廓分明的嘴唇，浓密的头发。这完全符合那个时代的美学理想。她直视观众的方式，大多数模特都不会这样做。在一些画作中，
even those where she's kind of playing a part in a historical or a kind of literary tableau, they are amazingly vivid. They look like kind of Instagram shots. So there's one in particular where she's playing the part of Titania in Mid-Summer Night's Dream. And she looks like a snap of, of a girl enjoying a picnic, incredibly vivid.
即使是那些她在历史或文学场景中扮演角色的画作，它们也令人惊叹地生动。它们看起来像Instagram照片。有一个特别的例子，她扮演《仲夏夜之梦》中的提泰妮娅。她看起来像一个享受野餐的女孩的快照，极其生动。
She's also very chameleon-like. So she can be painted as a nun or she can be painted as a baccanti. You know, one of those women out tearing people to pieces up on the uplands of Thebes. And then there's the riddle of her identity. Now, who is she? Who is Emma Hart? This enigmatic woman. Because most women who appear on prints are already famous.
她也非常像变色龙。所以她可以被画成修女，也可以被画成酒神女祭司。你知道，那些在底比斯高地上把人撕成碎片的女人。然后是她身份的谜团。她是谁？艾玛·哈特是谁？这个神秘的女人。因为大多数出现在版画上的女性都已经很有名了。
They are aristocrats. They are actresses. or whatever, Emma isn't. And this generates an absolute obsession. People want to know more about her. You know, the chance to meet her is a kind of incredible thrill. And when people come and they watch her and she's dressed in this kind of clinging classical styles of robes, very similar to the kind that she'd worn on the vast erotic bed.
她们是贵族。她们是女演员，等等，艾玛不是。这产生了一种绝对的痴迷。人们想更多地了解她。你知道，见到她的机会是一种令人难以置信的刺激。当人们来观看她时，她穿着这种紧身的古典风格长袍，非常类似于她在巨大的色情床上穿的那种。
And, of course, hugely fashionable at this point. Late 18th century, you know, everyone loves all the idea of the kind of new freedoms of dress and the classical lines and so on, no? Yeah, and Emma becomes the figurehead for that. She's basically the kind of the Kate Moss of this revolution in fashion. And Romney, I think, is kind of playing the part of John Galliano or Alexander McQueen to her Kate Moss. But it is very collaborative because, of course, you know, Emma has absolutely her own sense
当然，在这一点上非常时髦。18世纪末，你知道，每个人都喜欢关于服装的新自由和古典线条等等的想法，不是吗？是的，艾玛成为了那个标志。她基本上是这场时尚革命的凯特·莫斯。而罗姆尼，我认为，在扮演约翰·加利亚诺或亚历山大·麦昆的角色，而她是他的凯特·莫斯。但这非常具有协作性，因为当然，你知道，艾玛绝对有她自己的
of fashion. She knows what she looks good in. You can see why basically she becomes the pin-up girl for this new style of fashion that will, you know, sweet Britain. But if Romney and the female shoppers of London adore Emma in her classical outfits, there is Dominic another man who is even more bowled over by her. This is Greville's uncle, right? Now we come to the other man, the third man of the Nelson Emma triangle.
时尚感。她知道自己穿什么好看。你可以看出为什么她基本上成为了这种将席卷英国的新时尚风格的招贴画女孩。但如果罗姆尼和伦敦的女购物者崇拜古典装扮的艾玛，多米尼克，还有另一个男人更被她迷住了。这是格雷维尔的叔叔，对吧？现在我们谈到另一个男人，纳尔逊-艾玛三角恋的第三个男人。
And this is Britain's envoy to Naples, Greville's uncle, Sir William Hamilton. And he first meets her when I've just checked, he was 53. So he'd been away. He'd been in Naples for the last five years. He comes back to England, 1783, and his wife has recently died. And Emma is 35 years his junior. So that would make her, what is she? She's in her late teens.
这就是英国驻那不勒斯公使，格雷维尔的叔叔，威廉·汉密尔顿爵士。他第一次见到她时，我刚查过，他53岁。所以他一直不在。他在那不勒斯待了五年。他回到英国，1783年，他的妻子刚去世。艾玛比他小35岁。所以那意味着她，她多大？她十几岁。
Yeah. Right? She's in her late teens. And he's 53, but he thinks she is absolutely brilliant. I mean, he's completely, he's, it's infatuated too strong? No, not at all. He's absolutely blown away by her. And Emma, in turn, you know, she's like the girl from the pop song.
对吧？她十几岁。他53岁，但他认为她绝对出色。我的意思是，他完全，他，迷恋这个词太强烈了吗？不，一点也不。他完全被她迷住了。而艾玛，反过来，你知道，她就像流行歌曲里的女孩。
She has a thirst for knowledge. And William Hamilton, you know, he's got a lot of knowledge because he's an unbelievable connoisseur. He loves a vase, doesn't he? He loves the vase. Pompeii and Herculaneum are being kind of dug up at this point. He probably knows more about Greek and Roman vases than anyone else in Europe at this point. Fascinating. Well, he's also a very keen volcanologist, Dominic.
她有求知欲。而威廉·汉密尔顿，你知道，他有很多知识，因为他是一位令人难以置信的鉴赏家。他喜欢花瓶，不是吗？他喜欢花瓶。庞贝和赫库兰尼姆在这一点上正在被挖掘。他可能比欧洲任何人都更了解希腊和罗马花瓶。迷人。嗯，他也是一位非常热衷的火山学家，多米尼克。
Okay. So he's always climbing Mount Vesuvius, and he is, he's fun. He's very stylish, he dresses well, he's witty, he's charismatic. You can see why they would get on. That's the side of him that's always lost, isn't it? I was thinking about this. So later on, when Nelson enters the story, Sir William Hamilton is treated by cartoonists and by satirists as a total joke,
好的。所以他总是爬维苏威火山，而且他，他很有趣。他很时髦，穿得很好，他风趣、有魅力。你可以看出为什么他们会相处得来。那是他总是被遗忘的一面，不是吗？我一直在想这个。所以后来，当纳尔逊进入故事时，威廉·汉密尔顿爵士被漫画家和讽刺作家当作一个彻头彻尾的笑话，
as a doddery, old fool who doesn't know what's going on. Cuckold, yeah. Yeah, just as a sort of a hapless, wet, weak loser. Yeah. And actually, he's not. He's a much more serious and more charming and more sophisticated person than that. Yeah. And Revel by this point doesn't mind a bit because he's getting a bit bored of Emma, I think.
一个不知道发生了什么的糊涂老傻瓜。戴绿帽子的，对。是的，只是一个倒霉的、软弱的、失败者。是的。实际上，他不是。他是一个比那更严肃、更迷人、更复杂的人。是的。而格雷维尔在这一点上并不介意，因为我想他开始对艾玛感到有点厌倦了。
And also he wants to marry. He's very short of cash. And, you know, Emma slightly gets in the way of that plan. You said, you know, does he feel fond for Emma? I think he does. He doesn't want to do her Sir Harry and just dump her. He wants to secure her future. And so he comes up with a brilliant.
而且他也想结婚。他非常缺钱。而且，你知道，艾玛稍微阻碍了那个计划。你说，你知道，他对艾玛有感情吗？我想他有。他不想像哈里爵士那样对待她，只是抛弃她。他想确保她的未来。所以他想出了一个绝妙的
Wees. Why doesn't he send Emma to Naples to Uncle William? And she can become Sir William's mistress. Yeah. So he writes to his uncle and says, I've got, it's a brilliant idea. What about it? And Sir William says, yeah, great. I mean, if she's on for it. And Greville lies and says, yeah, she's absolutely on for it. I've told her. He hasn't told her this at all because he knows that she won't go. Right. She's actually very devoted to Greville. So then he gets her to go with her mother by saying, you go out and join Sir William, and I will join you a week later. So Emma sets off for Naples. It takes her a month to get there. She arrives on her 21st birthday, 26th of April, 1786. And within days, she realizes that she's been tricked. Greville has completely sown her up.
主意。他为什么不把艾玛送到那不勒斯给威廉叔叔呢？她可以成为威廉爵士的情妇。是的。所以他写信给他的叔叔说，我有一个绝妙的主意。怎么样？威廉爵士说，好，太棒了。如果她愿意的话。格雷维尔撒谎说，是的，她绝对愿意。我告诉过她了。他根本没告诉她，因为他知道她不会去。对。她实际上非常忠于格雷维尔。所以他让她和她母亲一起去，说，你去和威廉爵士团聚，我一周后会去。所以艾玛出发前往那不勒斯。她花了一个月才到达。她在21岁生日那天到达，1786年4月26日。几天之内，她意识到自己被骗了。格雷维尔完全把她卖了。
And Emma is devastated, and to the surprise of both uncle and nephew, she refuses to go to bed with Sir William. And I think both Greville and Sir William had assumed that she would, that she's a good time girl. Of course she will. But she doesn't. Actually, Emma is a romantic. She has plighted her troth to Greville. She wants the security that he provided, I think both emotional and financial. And she's not prepared to just kind of move on to the very aged Sir William. And that July, she writes to Greville and says, if I was with you, I would murder you and myself both. Gregie. And yet, over time. And yet. Yeah. And yet. Over time. So six months. basically, she still enables and eventually, you know, the flame of her ardour for gravel
艾玛崩溃了，令叔侄俩惊讶的是，她拒绝和威廉爵士上床。我想格雷维尔和威廉爵士都以为她会，她是个玩得开的女孩。当然她会。但她没有。实际上，艾玛是个浪漫主义者。她已经向格雷维尔许下了诺言。她想要他提供的安全感，我想既是情感上的也是经济上的。她还没准备好就这样转投年迈的威廉爵士。那年七月，她写信给格雷维尔说，如果我和你在一起，我会杀了你和我自己。格雷吉。然而，随着时间的推移。然而。是的。然而。随着时间的推移。所以六个月。
dies out and she actually thinks, now, is this just calculation or what is it? She thinks, I will go to bed with Sir William after all. She has no real choice. Right. I mean, you know, the only choice she has, she's in the foreign country where she doesn't really speak the language. She will be penniless otherwise. Yeah, so by December, she is writing to William saying, yes, I love you. Soon afterwards, it seems she begins sleeping with him. By 1789, She's dropping heavy hints to visitors that she and Sir William are married, which Sir William does nothing to deny. And then in 1791, Sir William and Emma returned to England, and there Sir William, he's got the permission of the king himself to marry Emma. And on the 6th of September, 1791, in a private ceremony at Marylebone, Sir William Hamilton, envoy of his majesty to the Court of Naples.
基本上，她仍然被困住，最终，你知道，她对格雷维尔的热情之火熄灭了，她实际上想，现在，这只是算计还是什么？她想，我终究还是会和威廉爵士上床。她别无选择。对。我的意思是，你知道，她唯一的选择，她在外国，她不太会说那里的语言。否则她将一贫如洗。是的，所以到了十二月，她写信给威廉说，是的，我爱你。不久之后，似乎她开始和他睡觉了。到了1789年，她开始向访客暗示她和威廉爵士结婚了，威廉爵士对此并没有否认。然后在1791年，威廉爵士和艾玛回到英国，在那里威廉爵士得到了国王本人的许可娶艾玛。1791年9月6日，在马里波恩的一个私人仪式上，威廉·汉密尔顿爵士，陛下驻那不勒斯宫廷的公使。
And the one time housemaid and streetwalker, Amy Lyon, become man and wife. And obviously for Emma, this is the fulfillment of all her dreams, because right from the moment of her arrival in Naples, Sir William had been lavishing her with horses and dresses and servants and houses and gorgeous views over the Bay of Naples and everything. And now, as his wife, she can be confident that all of these are hers by matrimonoma. right, but it's not just material, she's not just being materialist about this. She's surely, I mean, it's easy for people to see this as a purely mercenary and cold-blooded relationship.
和曾经的女佣和街头妓女，艾米·里昂，成为了夫妻。显然对艾玛来说，这是她所有梦想的实现，因为从她到达那不勒斯的那一刻起，威廉爵士就一直用马匹、衣服、仆人、房子和那不勒斯湾的美景以及一切来宠爱她。现在，作为他的妻子，她可以确信所有这些都是她通过婚姻合法拥有的。对，但这不仅仅是物质，她不仅仅是在这方面物质主义。她肯定，我的意思是，人们很容易把这看作是一种纯粹的唯利是图和冷血的关系。
But all the evidence we have is that they actually were very fond of each other. They got on very well, that he is very nice to her, he's very encouraging. I mean, people did mock him later on, they said, oh, he's infatuated with her, she can do no wrong, all of this kind of thing. But obviously, they lived together for
但我们拥有的所有证据都表明他们实际上非常喜欢对方。他们相处得很好，他对他非常好，他非常鼓励她。我的意思是，人们后来确实嘲笑他，他们说，哦，他被她迷住了，她做什么都不会错，所有这类事情。但显然，他们住在一起
many years, very successfully and very happily. He's a very kind and loving husband. And I think that Emma, who had been denied kindness and love for most of her life, this is what she'd wanted perhaps even more than kind of fine horses and clothes. Emotional security, respect, she feels seen by him, all of those kinds of things. Yeah, and that's really important. He respects her as well as adores her. he is angered by the snobbery with which his marriage to her is greeted.
很多年，非常成功且非常幸福。他是一个非常善良和充满爱心的丈夫。我认为艾玛，她一生中大部分时间都被剥夺了善良和爱，这也许是她想要的，甚至超过了名马和衣服。情感安全，尊重，她觉得被他看见，所有这些事情。是的，这真的很重要。他尊重她，也崇拜她。他对人们以势利眼对待他与她的婚姻感到愤怒。
So, Lady Holland, a wig, very, very snobbish about it, that he should admire her beauty is not singular, but that he should like her society certainly is, as it is impossible to go beyond her in vulgarity and coarseness. That's the opinion of Lady Holland. Right. But Sir William, this kind of attitude infuriates him. I mean, maybe it's because he's a kind of connoisseur of female beauty and character
所以，荷兰夫人，一个辉格党人，对此非常非常势利，他应该欣赏她的美貌并不奇怪，但如果他喜欢她的社交圈那肯定很奇怪，因为在粗俗和粗鲁方面不可能超过她。那是荷兰夫人的观点。对。但威廉爵士，这种态度激怒了他。我的意思是，也许是因为他是一位女性美和性格的鉴赏家
as well as of, you know, Greek vases, he can recognize in her all kinds of qualities in addition to her incredible beauty. So those qualities would include the fact she's very smart. She's had no education as a child. And so she has that kind of autodactic enthusiasm. She wants to learn. She wants to improve herself all the time. So William gets her French teachers. She picks up very fluent Italian, very, very fast. She shares in her husband's passions. So she's always scrambling up Vesuvius with him. She studies classical art. So she becomes very familiar with the classical statues and portraits on barses and things that Sir William loves.
以及希腊花瓶的鉴赏家，他能在她身上认出除了她令人难以置信的美貌之外的各种品质。所以这些品质包括她非常聪明。她小时候没有受过教育。所以她有那种自学成才的热情。她想学习。她一直想提升自己。威廉给她找了法语老师。她学得非常快，意大利语非常流利。她分享她丈夫的热情。所以她总是和他一起爬维苏威火山。她研究古典艺术。所以她变得非常熟悉威廉爵士喜爱的古典雕像和花瓶上的肖像等等。
And this in turn is what then feeds into the attitudes. Right. Now, just before we come to the attitudes, just to remind people, there is a huge age gap here. I mean, Theo just said in the chat, how old is she? She was 26 in 1791 when they got married. He was 61. on. So, you know, that's also part of the, and a really, really important part of the dynamic. But let's get back to the attitudes because this is the core you think of her appeal. And you
这反过来又滋养了她的姿态。对。现在，在我们谈到姿态之前，提醒大家，这里有巨大的年龄差距。我的意思是，西奥刚才在聊天中说，她多大了？1791年他们结婚时她26岁。他61岁。所以，你知道，这也是其中的一部分，而且是动态中非常非常重要的一部分。但让我们回到姿态，因为这是你认为她吸引力的核心。而你
have totally signed up. I have. I mean, Tom, let's be honest, you have completely drunk the attitude. I don't want to say you drunk the Kool-Aid, but I just want to leave that image hanging there. Tell us why these attitudes are so revelatory and so radical and exciting. Let's be upfront. There is absolutely an element of the dirty old man about Sir William. in this, I think. He's the guy who kind of fixes the lighting, does the staging. Yes. Just pull your dress away a little bit more, my dear. Yeah, there's no question that it is erotic, but it is also simultaneously learned. So in a way, it's Sir William's dream. It's kind of sexy, but also redolent of, you know, antiques vases.
完全赞同。我赞同。我的意思是，汤姆，老实说，你完全喝下了姿态的迷魂汤。我不想说你喝了邪教的毒药，但我只是想让那个形象悬在那里。告诉我们为什么这些姿态如此具有启发性、如此激进和令人兴奋。让我们坦率地说。威廉爵士在这方面绝对有一种肮脏老男人的成分。我想。他是那种修理灯光、进行舞台布置的人。是的。再把你的裙子拉开一点，亲爱的。是的，毫无疑问它是色情的，但它同时也很有学问。所以从某种意义上说，这是威廉爵士的梦想。它有点性感，但也让人想起，你知道，古董花瓶。
I wish that Venus on my vase would come to life. Oh, she has. But it's much more than that. You know, as I said at the beginning, spectacle, of a statue seemingly coming to life, an image from a vase, being given flesh and blood. It enthuses and enraptures and astonishes people from across the whole of Europe, including most famously Gerta. And Gertes' praise makes Emma's attitudes, basically the kind of the hottest ticket in Europe. She is an international star.
我希望我花瓶上的维纳斯能活过来。哦，她活过来了。但这不仅仅是那样。你知道，正如我在开头所说，奇观，一个雕像似乎活了过来，一个花瓶上的形象，被赋予了血肉之躯。它激励、迷住了来自欧洲各地的人们，包括最著名的歌德。而歌德的赞美使艾玛的姿态基本上成为了欧洲最热门的门票。她是一位国际明星。
She's a must-see fixture for high society visits to Naples. And I will quote the historian Gillian Russell on this. She's a formative influence on the imagination of poets and artists, making Emma a key figure, Dominic, in the fusion of neoclassicism with sensibility that was to characterize the European-wide cultural movement, later known as Romanticism. So she is taking that 18th century obsession with the classical, fusing it with the great cult of sensibility, and she is the great precursor of romanticism. So in that, she's very like probably the two most famous men of the 19th century.
她是高层社会访问那不勒斯的必看景点。我将引用历史学家吉莉安·拉塞尔的话。她是诗人艺术家想象力的形成性影响，使艾玛成为关键人物，多米尼克，在新古典主义与感性融合中，这将成为后来被称为浪漫主义的欧洲文化运动的特征。所以她正在吸收那种18世纪对古典的痴迷，将其与伟大的感性崇拜融合，她是浪漫主义的伟大先驱。所以在这方面，她非常像19世纪最著名的两个男人。
Napoleon and Byron. You're claiming that Lord Byron is one of the two most famous men of the 19th century. Yes, of course. That's a mad claim, but continue? No, it's not. Absolutely not. We won't go into that. He's more famous than Bismarck or Disraeli.
拿破仑和拜伦。你声称拜伦勋爵是19世纪最著名的两个男人之一。是的，当然。这是一个疯狂的说法，但请继续？不，不是。绝对不是。我们不会深入讨论那个。他比俾斯麦或迪斯雷利更出名。
Yes, massively. Continue. Napoleon and Byron are famous as cultural figures who haunt the imaginings of generation after generation after generation. Emma doesn't have that impact because what she is doing is dependent on live performance. And so once she's gone, memories of it fade. But while she's doing these, it clearly does have a massive kind of influence on the way that poets and artists are starting to think of what will come to be called the romantic. But the influence of these attitudes, obviously, it's not just intellectual, because it's also a huge influence in the shops and the ballrooms of Britain.
是的，非常出名。继续。拿破仑和拜伦作为文化人物而闻名，他们困扰着一代又一代人的想象。艾玛没有那种影响，因为她所做的是依赖现场表演。所以一旦她走了，记忆就会褪色。但当她做这些时，它显然对诗人和艺术家开始思考后来被称为浪漫主义的东西产生了巨大的影响。但这些姿态的影响，显然，不仅仅是智力上的，因为它在英国的商店和舞厅里也有巨大的影响。
Emma is a massive influence on the kind of growing classical turn of women's dress. She'd been as an artist's model, but even more now that she has these attitudes, the kind of the most famous floor show, in Europe, her ability to serve as a muse for designers and indeed for shoppers is obviously being massively fueled by industrialization, which enables kind of rapid turnover of fashion. And so again, I think you could say that Emma is kind of one of the first great influencers. And I think we actually talked about her role in this in the episode on this we did with Hillary Davidson, the Regency Revolution. She is a major influence both on culture and on shopping. basically. And you can tell her impact that as the years pass, even members of the highest
艾玛对女性服装日益增长的古典转向产生了巨大的影响。她曾是一名艺术模特，但现在她有了这些姿态，欧洲最著名的地板秀，她作为设计师甚至购物者的缪斯的能力显然受到了工业化的巨大推动，这使得时尚的快速周转成为可能。所以再次，我认为你可以说艾玛是第一批伟大的网红之一。我想我们实际上在和希拉里·戴维森做的关于摄政革命的那一集中谈到了她在这一方面的作用。她基本上对文化和购物都有重大影响。你可以看出她的影响，随着岁月的流逝，即使是最高层
society start to experience something of her star quality. You know, they start to dress like Lady Hamilton. Some even compliment her personally. So here is, here's Lady Palmerston. Lady H is to me very surprising for considering the situation she was in. She behaves wonderfully well now and then to be sure a little vulgarness pops out. But I think it's more Sir William's fault. who loves a good joke and leads her to enter into his stories, which are not of the best kind. Not of the best kind, I mean, that's very telling, isn't it? That's basically he wants her to play a part in his sort of erotic fantasies, no? I don't think it's just that. I think it reflects the fact in which they're very close as a couple and that they're always working as a team.
社会的人也开始体验到她的一些明星品质。你知道，她们开始像汉密尔顿夫人一样穿衣。有些人甚至亲自赞美她。所以这是帕默斯顿夫人。汉密尔顿夫人对我来说非常令人惊讶，因为考虑到她所处的境地。她现在表现得非常好，偶尔肯定会冒出一点粗俗。但我认为这更多是威廉爵士的错。他喜欢开玩笑，引导她进入他的故事，这些故事不是最好的那种。不是最好的那种，我的意思是，这非常能说明问题，不是吗？这基本上是他想让她在他的某种色情幻想中扮演一个角色，不是吗？我不认为仅仅是那样。我认为这反映了他们作为一对夫妇非常亲密，而且他们总是作为一个团队在工作。
And this in turn helps to explain the other way in which Emma is very useful to Sir William, which is as a kind of a political operator. And it's the, measure of Emma's charm that she's able to befriend someone far grander than, you know, Lady Palmerston, even than Lady Holland. And this is the most powerful queen in Europe, because Maria Carolina, she is Habsburg, she is the elder sister of Marianne Twinnett, and she is the wife of the Bourbon King, Ferdinand IV, of Naples and Sicily. Right. And she is effectively the ruler of his kingdom. And this is because Ferdinand, is an absolute boar.
这反过来有助于解释艾玛对威廉爵士非常有用的另一种方式，即作为一种政治操作者。艾玛的魅力在于她能够结交比帕默斯顿夫人、甚至比荷兰夫人更显赫的人。这就是欧洲最强大的女王，因为玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜，她是哈布斯堡家族的，她是玛丽·安托瓦内特的姐姐，她是那不勒斯和西西里波旁国王费迪南德四世的妻子。对。她实际上是她王国的统治者。这是因为费迪南德是一个彻头彻尾的野猪。
He's an oaf. He's an absolute oaf. Yeah, John Sugden brilliantly describes him as a boisterous, big-featured buffoon. So, like another Habsburg, Franz Ferdinand, he's absolutely obsessed with killing animals. He loves hunting. He would chase his courtiers around the palace with throwing the contents of a chamber pot at them. Yes. Throwing frogs at them and stuff like this. That's his idea of a great laugh.
他是一个笨蛋。他是一个彻头彻尾的笨蛋。是的，约翰·萨格登出色地描述他为一个喧闹、大特征的丑角。所以，像另一个哈布斯堡家族成员弗朗茨·费迪南德一样，他绝对痴迷于杀害动物。他喜欢狩猎。他会把尿壶里的东西扔向他的朝臣，在宫殿里追赶他们。是的。向他们扔青蛙之类的东西。那是他认为的伟大笑话。
Yeah, absolutely bans. He also has a very shrill falsetto. So he's like a Neantatal. unlike Maria Carolina, who has a very deep voice. Yes. So they're an entertaining couple. But he's very dissipated and inevitably, therefore, had tried to seduce Emma. But she had pretended that she had no idea what he meant by these advances and rebuffs them.
是的，绝对禁止。他还有一个非常尖锐的假声。所以他像个尼安德特人。不像玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜，她有一个非常低沉的声音。是的。所以他们是一对有趣的夫妇。但他非常放荡，因此不可避免地试图引诱艾玛。但她假装不知道他这些举动是什么意思，并拒绝了它们。
And Maria Carolina is very grateful for this and hails Emma as an absolute model of virtue. But obviously, for as long as Emma is not married to Sir William, she can't receive her. you know, that would just be an absolute no-no. But she's always encouraging Sir William to make an honest woman of Emma. They do to go to England and get married, as we've heard. And on their journey back to Naples from, you know, the time they spent in England when they got married, they have a stop over in Paris. And this is 1791. And it's three months after the abortive escape made by Louis XVI and Marie Antoinette, which gets stopped at Varenne and they get brought back. And Sir William and Emma in the Assembly when Louis the 16th is forced to accept the, you know, the radical constitution,
玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜对此非常感激，并称艾玛为绝对的道德典范。但显然，只要艾玛没有嫁给威廉爵士，她就不能接待她。你知道，那绝对是不可能的。但她总是鼓励威廉爵士让艾玛成为一个诚实的女人。他们确实去英国结婚了，正如我们所听到的。在他们从英国结婚后返回那不勒斯的旅途中，他们在巴黎停留。这是1791年。这是路易十六和玛丽·安托瓦内特那次失败的逃跑三个月后，他们在瓦雷讷被拦住并被带回。威廉爵士和艾玛在议会中，当时路易十六被迫接受激进的宪法，
which classes him essentially as a constitutional monarch. And we've done this in our series on the French Revolution. You know, he's forced to sit on a kind of plain chair. Stuff with hats. A lot of hat action. Lots of stuff with hats. Nobody takes their hats off. And he's, he's very upset and humiliated. As of course is Marie Antoinette. Even though Maria Carolina had refused to receive Emma, Marie Antoinette doesn't care about this. She says, sees Emma and gives her a letter for her older sister. And for Emma, I mean, you can imagine this is, this is amazing. And it enables her to rank as the only person who meets both Marie Antoinette and sleeps with Nelson.
这使他本质上成为了一位立宪君主。我们在法国大革命系列节目中已经讲过这一点。你知道，他被迫坐在一种普通的椅子上。到处都是帽子。有很多关于帽子的戏份。到处都是帽子。没人摘下帽子。他感到非常沮丧和羞辱。玛丽·安托瓦内特当然也一样。尽管玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜拒绝接见艾玛，但玛丽·安托瓦内特并不在乎。她见到艾玛，并给了她一封写给她姐姐的信。对于艾玛来说，你可以想象，这太不可思议了。这使她成为唯一一个既见过玛丽·安托瓦内特又与纳尔逊同床共枕的人。
So that is quite an achievement. Yeah. And a month after she's got back to Naples, as Sir William's wife, as Lady Hamilton, she's invited to her first private audience with Maria Carolina. And Emma talks to her about Mariantoinette. and she's so emotional about it. She's so overcome with sorrow for Marie Antoinette's situation that she bursts into tears.
所以这确实是一项了不起的成就。是的。在她回到那不勒斯一个月后，作为威廉爵士的妻子，作为汉密尔顿夫人，她受邀参加了与玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜的第一次私人会见。艾玛向她谈起了玛丽·安托瓦内特。她对此非常激动。她对玛丽·安托瓦内特的处境感到无比悲伤，以至于泪流满面。
And Maria Carolina is incredibly touched by this. And soon after Sir William and Emma are invited to spend the hunting season at Caserta, which is the kind of the great Neapolitan Versailles, and it isn't long before she and the Queen are absolute intimates. Right. And for Maria Carolina, the snobbery that would surround Emma in England is not quite the same in Naples. She's just a foreigner.
玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜对此深受感动。不久之后，威廉爵士和艾玛受邀在卡塞塔度过狩猎季节，那里就像是那不勒斯的凡尔赛宫。没过多久，她和王后就成了绝对的密友。没错。对于玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜来说，在英国围绕艾玛的势利眼在那不勒斯并不完全一样。她只是个外国人。
And Emma is fun. Emma's a good laugh. Emma's not, you know, sort of tainted by the factionism of the court. Yeah. Politically, they're on the same page, aren't they? Because Emma is a classic working class aspirational Tory. She's a big royalist and a big reactionary. Yeah, she loves kings and queens.
而且艾玛很有趣。艾玛是个开心果。艾玛没有被宫廷的派系斗争所玷污。是的。在政治上，她们志同道合，不是吗？因为艾玛是一个典型的渴望跻身上流社会的工人阶级托利党人。她是一个坚定的保皇派和反动派。是的，她热爱国王和王后。
Absolutely. But also, you know, she has been a lady's made to actresses. She has resources in her lived experience. that enable her, I think, to get on very well with Maria Carolina. And as you said, the fact that they're communicating in Italian and French means that there's no opportunity for the Queen to sneer at Emma's Lancastrian accent, which she keeps all her life. Meanwhile, of course, the French Revolution is starting to become bloodier,
绝对是这样。但同时，你知道，她曾做过女演员的女仆。她的生活经历赋予了她资源，我认为这使她能与玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜相处得很好。正如你所说，她们用意大利语和法语交流，这意味着王后没有机会嘲笑艾玛那终生未改的兰开夏口音。当然，与此同时，法国大革命开始变得更加血腥，
due to the 16th is sent to the guillotine, Marianneux sent to the guillotine, and the storm clouds of war are gathering over Europe. Europe. And Maria Carolina, understandably, is terrified of the French. Emma wants to help secure ports in the Mediterranean for the Royal Navy. And basically, the interests of the two women coincide. And in 1793, when a young captain called Horatio Nelson arrives in Naples with the task of recruiting from Ferdinand IV, troops that, can join the siege of Toulon. It is Emma who oils the wheels of power for him and sources him the reinforcements that the British need for the siege.
路易十六被送上断头台，玛丽·安托瓦内特被送上断头台，战争的阴云笼罩着欧洲。玛丽亚·卡罗琳娜理所当然地对法国人感到恐惧。艾玛想帮助皇家海军确保地中海港口的安全。基本上，这两位女性的利益是一致的。1793年，当一位名叫霍雷肖·纳尔逊的年轻船长抵达那不勒斯，任务是从费迪南德四世那里招募军队以参加土伦围城战时，是艾玛为他疏通了权力关系，并为他争取到了英国围城战所需的增援。
Right, because Naples is crucial for the British in the Mediterranean because they have so few bases. And if they can get the support of Naples, which is obviously a reactionary, anti-revolutionary power, that would be a massive, massive boost. And that's where Sir William,
没错，因为那不勒斯对地中海的英国人来说至关重要，因为他们的基地太少了。如果他们能得到那不勒斯的支持，那显然是一个反动、反革命的政权，那将是一个巨大的推动力。这就是威廉爵士发挥作用的地方，
who is basically the ambassador in Naples and his wife are so important. Yes. And Nelson is very, very grateful to Emma, very impressed by her. He sees her intimacy with the Queen. He thinks that's very impressive. Also her command of foreign languages. Nelson's hopeless with languages.
他基本上是那不勒斯的大使，他和他的妻子非常重要。是的。纳尔逊对艾玛非常感激，对她印象深刻。他看到了她与王后的亲密关系。他认为这非常了不起。还有她对外国语言的掌握。纳尔逊对语言一窍不通。
He's also very impressed by that. And he's impressed by her charm, by her beauty, and by her strong dislike of the French, which of course Nelson also has. And so I think he does leave Naples with a certain tondres, perhaps. Nelson then goes off, you know, he's sailing around the Mediterranean and then the Atlantic all the time. It doesn't have time for Emma at all, barely thinks of her. And meanwhile, Emma and the Queen huddle together, kind of dreading that revolution will come to Naples. And by 1798, it seems that the revolution is kind of lapping at the gates of Naples, because the streets of the city are absolutely seething.
他也对这一点印象深刻。他被她的魅力、美貌以及她对法国人的强烈厌恶所打动，当然纳尔逊也有这种厌恶。所以我认为他离开那不勒斯时确实带有一种爱慕之情。纳尔逊随后离开了，你知道，他一直在地中海和大西洋航行。他根本没时间想艾玛，几乎没想起过她。与此同时，艾玛和王后聚在一起，担心革命会波及那不勒斯。到了1798年，革命似乎已经蔓延到了那不勒斯的门口，因为这座城市的街道上已经沸腾了。
there are Jacobins out there, and in February 1798, the French Occupy Rome, which is no distance at all from Naples. Meanwhile, news is sweeping Naples that a massive French task force under the greatest general of the Revolutionary Republic, Napoleon Bonaparte, is setting sailed from Toulon, the Great Port on the south of the Mediterranean that the British had briefly captured and then lost again, and now a fleet is sailing out. from it under Napoleon, and nobody knows where it's going. And Emma is convinced that Napoleon is heading for Naples to conquer the south of Italy. And so she writes to the supreme commander of the British Navy, the Earl of St. Vincent, and says, please come and rescue us.
外面有雅各宾派，1798年2月，法国人占领了罗马，离那不勒斯近在咫尺。与此同时，那不勒斯传出消息，一支由革命共和国最伟大的将军拿破仑·波拿巴率领的庞大法国特遣部队，正从土伦启航。土伦是地中海南部的一个大港口，英国人曾短暂占领又失去，现在一支舰队在拿破仑的率领下从那里驶出，没人知道它要去哪里。艾玛确信拿破仑正前往那不勒斯以征服意大利南部。于是她写信给英国海军最高指挥官圣文森特伯爵，说，请来救救我们。
You know, we are, we are the target of this terrifying monster Bonaparte. And Sir Vincent duly promises assistance, and he says it will come under the command of a knight of superior proes in my train, who is charged with this enterprise and will soon make his appearance. And Dominic, who is this knight of superior proes? It is Horatio Nelson. But of course, Napoleon, I mean, they did think, you know, we talked when we did the Nelson series, about how Nelson and his captains did wonder if Napoleon was
你知道，我们是这个可怕的怪物波拿巴的目标。圣文森特如约承诺提供援助，他说援助将由我麾下的一位卓越骑士指挥，他负责这项事业，很快就会出现。多米尼克，这位卓越的骑士是谁？正是霍雷肖·纳尔逊。但当然，拿破仑，我的意思是，他们确实想过，我们在做纳尔逊系列节目时谈到过，纳尔逊和他的船长们确实怀疑拿破仑是否
heading for Naples. It was a real concern of theirs. But Napoleon and his armament are actually heading for Egypt, aren't they? and Nelson does he does pass Naples and he sends Emma a note he does he sends her a letter and says I hope to kiss your hand very soon but that's just him being gallant as he you know being polite and gallant right that's not there's no significance there particularly yeah I think so but isn't there some story that she does have to grease the wheels again because he goes to Syracuse and he's not going to be let in yeah so so people may remember that Nelson is looking for the French fleet and you can't find it he's got the whole of the Mediterranean's like looking for a needle in a haystack, and he sails all the way to Egypt on the assumption that Napoleon might be going there. There's nothing there. He then sails back to Sicily, to Syracuse, where he's told, oh yeah, Napoleon is, you know, he is bound for Egypt. But it's like kind of a filling your car with petrol. He needs supplies to make that journey back. And the commander
正前往那不勒斯。这是他们真正关心的问题。但拿破仑和他的武装实际上是前往埃及，不是吗？纳尔逊确实经过了那不勒斯，他给艾玛写了一张便条，他确实写了一封信说，我希望很快能亲吻你的手，但这只是他表现得风度翩翩，你知道，表现得礼貌而风度翩翩，对吧？这没什么特别的意义。是的，我想是这样。但有没有什么故事说她确实不得不再次疏通关系，因为他去了锡拉库萨，却不被允许进入？是的，所以人们可能记得纳尔逊在寻找法国舰队，但他找不到。整个地中海就像大海捞针，他一直航行到埃及，假设拿破仑可能去了那里。那里什么都没有。然后他航行回西西里岛的锡拉库萨，在那里他被告知，哦，是的，拿破仑确实是去埃及的。但这就像给你的车加汽油一样。他需要补给才能完成那次返程。而锡拉库萨的指挥官
of Syracuse refuses to allow him in and refuses to give him supplies. And it is Emma who goes to the queen, goes to the king, sources the supplies. And Nelson is then able to sail off eastwards and on the 1st of August, he duly wins his great incomparable victory over the French at Abacier Bay. And that was the victory with which we ended our previous season. Yeah, the Battle in the Nile. So that was an absolutely transcendent moment for Nelson, just a crushing, crushing victory over the French as he wrote to. He writes to Sir William Hamilton, doesn't he? Victory is not strong enough a name for such a scene as I have passed. Yeah, he does. And so William and Lady Hamilton are absolutely thrilled, are they? Yeah. So Emma immediately passes the news on to
拒绝让他进入，也拒绝给他补给。是艾玛去找王后，去找国王，争取到了补给。纳尔逊随后得以向东航行，并在8月1日，他在阿布基尔湾赢得了对法国人的伟大而无与伦比的胜利。这就是我们上一季结束时的胜利。是的，尼罗河之战。这对纳尔逊来说是一个绝对超凡的时刻，正如他写给威廉·汉密尔顿爵士的那样，这是一场对法国人的毁灭性胜利。胜利这个词不足以形容我所经历的场景。是的，他确实这么写了。所以威廉和汉密尔顿夫人非常激动，是吗？是的。所以艾玛立即把这个消息传达给
the Queen, informing her of the joyful news for the great victory over the infernal French by the brave gallant Nelson. And of course, she dresses up alla Nelson. She has a dress specially made for her decorated with gold anchors. She has a sea blue shawl. She wears has a hairband inscribed Nelson and victory. And when on the 22nd of September, Nelson arrives in the Bay of Naples on his flagship, the vanguard, a rather embarrassing that the vanguard has to be towed in because it's lost its mast. She and Sir William are basically the first to arrive on the deck. And Emma is in an absolute lather of joy and patriotism.
王后，通知她勇敢的纳尔逊战胜了邪恶的法国人，这是一个令人高兴的消息。当然，她打扮成纳尔逊的样子。她特意为自己做了一件装饰着金锚的裙子。她有一条海蓝色的披肩。她戴着写有纳尔逊和胜利字样的发带。当9月22日纳尔逊乘坐他的旗舰先锋号抵达那不勒斯湾时，先锋号因为失去了桅杆而不得不被拖进来，这相当尴尬。她和威廉爵士基本上是第一批到达甲板上的人。艾玛沉浸在绝对的喜悦和爱国主义之中。
And she hurls herself onto the very battered and maimed admiral. And Nelson, who is, of course, himself, as we saw in our previous season, a great enthusiast for histrionic emotion. I mean, he indulges in it himself and he enjoys it in other people. He's completely charmed. And he writes to Fanny, his wife, who is mouldering away in a rectory back in Rainy Norfolk, up flew her ladyship and exclaiming, oh, God, is it possible, fell into my arms more dead than alive. and Kate Williams in her biography of Emma points out that so entranced was Nelson by Emma's display
她扑向那位伤痕累累的海军上将。纳尔逊本人，正如我们在上一季所见，是一个非常热衷于戏剧化情感的人。我的意思是，他自己沉溺于其中，也喜欢别人这样做。他完全被迷住了。他写信给他在雷尼诺福克郡的牧师住宅里逐渐衰老的妻子范妮说，夫人飞奔而来，惊呼道，哦，上帝，这可能吗？然后倒在我的怀里，几乎不省人事。凯特·威廉姆斯在她的艾玛传记中指出，纳尔逊被艾玛的表现迷住了，以至于
that he had temporarily forgotten he had only one arm. Oh, that's ominous. That's very ominous for those of us who are big Nelson fans. But Tom, where is this all leading? Well, we will find out on Monday, because on Monday we will be resuming the great journey through the life and victories of Horatio Nelson. be looking at Nelson in Naples. Does he cover himself in glory or not? We will find out. We will be examining the great romance of Nelson and Lady Hamilton. We'll be following him all the way to
他暂时忘记了自己只有一只手臂。哦，那是不祥的。对于我们这些纳尔逊的忠实粉丝来说，这非常不祥。但是汤姆，这一切指向哪里？好吧，我们周一就会知道，因为周一我们将继续霍雷肖·纳尔逊的生活和胜利的伟大旅程。我们将看看纳尔逊在那不勒斯。他是否获得了荣耀？我们会知道的。我们将审视纳尔逊和汉密尔顿夫人的伟大浪漫史。我们将跟随他一路前往
the Baltic and the Battle of Copenhagen. And then, now some people may say, oh, but what do then? Because they did a series about the Battle of Trafalgar. But Tom, we are nothing, if not a patriotic podcast. The anniversary of the Battle of Trafalgar is approaching. And although we have done it, We did it very much from our perspective, didn't we? We never did it from Nelson's perspective. Yeah. So I don't know what you think, but I think we should probably do Trafalgar through Nelson's eyes. I think we absolutely should.
波罗的海和哥本哈根战役。然后，现在有些人可能会说，哦，那之后呢？因为他们做了一个关于特拉法尔加海战的系列节目。但是汤姆，我们如果不是一个爱国播客，那我们就什么都不是。特拉法尔加海战的周年纪念日即将来临。虽然我们已经做过了，但我们确实是从我们的角度做的，不是吗？我们从来没有从纳尔逊的角度做过。是的。所以我不知道你怎么想，但我认为我们可能应该从纳尔逊的视角来做特拉法尔加。我认为我们绝对应该这样做。
I think that's what the people want. Yeah. We're not only a patriotic podcast, but we're the people's podcast. And what the people want, we do. Very much the people's podcast. And because we like people, we want to give people an opportunity to hear all that series early, to hear it straight away. Because we're all heart, aren't we? We are all heart.
我想这就是人们想要的。是的。我们不仅是一个爱国播客，我们还是人民的播客。人们想要什么，我们就做什么。非常名副其实的人民播客。因为我们喜欢人们，我们想给人们一个机会，让他们提前听到整个系列节目，让他们直接听到。因为我们都是热心肠，不是吗？我们都是热心肠。
Like Emma. Well, I mean, yeah, you can liken yourself to Emma Hamilton if you like. I'm still a little bit more skeptical about the attitudes. Members of the Rest Is History Club, our very own attitude's audience, can get access to the entire upcoming Nelson series. You will get it all from Monday. And if you're not already a member and you're not enjoying the host of benefits that come with membership, then you can sign up at the restishistory.com. So while you go and do that, it falls to me to say, Tom, that was absolutely fascinating. A brilliant window into George and London and to the life of this extraordinary character,
像艾玛一样。好吧，我的意思是，是的，如果你愿意，你可以把自己比作艾玛·汉密尔顿。我对这些态度仍然持一点怀疑态度。Rest Is History俱乐部的成员，我们自己的听众，可以获得整个即将推出的纳尔逊系列节目的访问权限。你将从周一开始获得所有内容。如果你还不是会员，也没有享受会员带来的诸多福利，那么你可以在restishistory.com注册。所以当你去这样做的时候，轮到我说，汤姆，这绝对令人着迷。这是了解乔治亚时代的伦敦以及这位非凡人物生活的一扇绝佳窗口，
with whom I have to say, I think you have rather like Sir William Hamilton. I think you have rather fallen in love, haven't you? Rather like Horatio Nelson, as we will see in the next episode. That is not the parallel. Thank you very much. Everyone for listening. Bye-bye. Goodbye.
我不得不说，我觉得你有点像威廉·汉密尔顿爵士。我想你已经坠入爱河了，不是吗？就像霍雷肖·纳尔逊一样，正如我们将在下一集中看到的那样。那不是平行线。非常感谢大家收听。再见。再见。
Thank you. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。